ladies and gentleman we have the the
Bible reading read I mean not often it
was a long time ago yeah but the Bible
living kevin Christie in the house
dressing very aggressively he's got the
kind of shoes the kind of tennis shoes
that a Chinese badminton player mm-hmm
or ping pong Clara wears right or
tourists wears okay black socks which I
appreciate yeah and you've got your
slacks but you are sporting a knife a
weapon I do I do I brought a knife yeah
and that's not for opening boxes it's
not like I was opening boxes all day
officer I do open a lot of boxes was
exciton line shop a lot okay but you
could open me up pretty quick with if
this [ __ ] hit the fan yeah I'm strapped
because on a physical level I know you
can take me so I need something to maybe
give me enough time to run yeah well no
I need to create a the tiniest bit of
hesitation in you no no no I know and I
and there would be edit a ssin yeah
until I use my feet you know I'm saying
bro no I'm gonna neutralize with no I
know I know
my plan is running yeah well I'm gonna
faint it's called a faint in the fight
world
okay I'm gonna faint you gonna cut but
you're gonna come up err yeah and then
and then what happens you've over
committed everyone's plan breaks down
yeah I wrote I think about this thing a
lot you remember that letter you wrote
to the guy about wanting to fight will
sasso yes bear versus dog I think about
that letter once every two weeks and I
think you wrote it like 12 years ago I
did and there was a part of your like
let me guess what your plan is kick the
knee like that's every novices plan
every now and then and I think about all
the time because the odds kolchin who's
5/8 165 to fight Will Sasso who's 330
and an athlete was a so I see he lives
in my neighborhood yeah first of all one
of the things people on the planet of
all yes no doubt and that guy he every
guys like cuz you look at him you're
like well I can't actually fight him
know so I'm going to have to just attack
the structure like I'm trying to bring
down a building yeah and so I'll go with
the knee the odds of connecting with the
knee in the way yeah it's that same like
I'll just punch him in the esophagus
okay and it's bad guy like
will is he's so big and he's so strong
and he's agile and he's agile but he's
also that rage like you can uncork that
rage having that much talent and not
being one of the most famous people in
the world yeah must create a fire yeah
yeah it does it well he's also got
what's what he refers to his FTS that
would be fat teenager syndrome it never
goes away it never goes away a fat kid
is always a fat kid on the inside
correct
forever forever yeah and and when you
watch the UFC and you watch guys break
their feet get their legs kicked tear
their ACL and keep fighting mm-hmm have
their nose smashed it wouldn't the
Adrenaline's going yep you're not you're
not stop until you kill the guy but it's
not like I'm gonna kick Will Sasso in
his knee and he's gonna go oh maybe if
he's at a cocktail party and he's a
little high and we're hanging out and I
go yeah Sasso kills you and doesn't
realize it any-any wakes up he's like
there's blood all over it stands and
he's like what you're like we'll
everyone's attendee is like oh no that's
exactly how I see it yeah I see him like
well well yeah there is a there's an
episode of cops from the 90s and it's it
I think it's in Philly and it's a naked
man who's cruising at about he's
probably six five looks about 250 like
easy he's booked completely naked and
also like completely moist head-to-toe
in sweat his own sweat cuz he's on meth
so stuff to hold on to yeah and he and
five cops try to tackle him in a very
narrow donut shop and I think about
alzheimer lows cops got to be like are
you [ __ ] kidding me
you earned your whole pension that day
yeah cuz this guy's slippery like a fish
and you could lose an eye or five of
them to get this guy down because he was
humongous and he was feeling no pain
yeah and did they tase the [ __ ] out of
them first you got a taste for I think
they could even get that close they were
like let the only the only like thing
they could do was like let's we have
five of us after Russia met once yeah it
was awful looking my buddies my buddies
surfers we're gonna he was surfing on
the wrong way of my buddies very tough
and they're gonna beat him up and my
buddy looked this is some Venice
locals-only bull yeah and my buddy look
to him when somebody's gonna lose an eye
somebody's gonna lose in those Yap who's
first mhm and they one guy recognized
him as this badass wrestler Oh actually
he's way too muscular and tall mad even
if you could beat a guy up it's like
well it's gonna be okay
when I was about 19 we used to go to
punk shows all the time my buddy Justin
big dude scholarship are played football
UCLA and that's t16 to 200 pounds yeah
was into jiu-jitsu in the early 90s
wet head so right with like Hicks and
Gracie and those geeks and Gracie tank
Abbott like early days where you could
do anything you want you could use the
fence you could punch a guy in the nuts
a million times yes just so much beat a
guy up in eighth grade and we were all
excited to see a fight and two seconds
after this fight started we were like
step up because it was so one-sided yeah
some dudes are closed that gap
oh you see the guy doing his flailing
underneath yeah it looked like a
professional fighter was beating up a
three-legged dog that's what Shaab can
do to pretty much anybody yeah it's just
like what like I'm in a job could kill a
PCP guy because he'd get him and choke
him yeah so no matter what you do you're
gonna when when the blood stops going to
your brain yeah which is what I train I
train I train only chokes bro I can do
it to myself but just with bad posture
so here well you're like a crustacean so
they would squeeze you in something else
would yeah you could you could Spock
touch me you know because I'm just so
poorly put together
well no no that's not sure what do you
train at all do you do any exercise I
play tennis
oh maybe two I play tennis all the time
are you a good test I am good I play
with Kirk Fox you do I do I'd love to
play tennis with you I love says the
tennis and this is it but but guys like
you who can will end up beating up
beating a lot of guys in tennis yeah
yeah no I'm good yeah I mean not Kirk
Kirk is he's something else Kirk's game
is disgusting he's a pro it's beautiful
the professor has a short hop inside-out
backhand
that's good everywhere in the world
really it is he will catch one on the
rise yeah
inside out and it is a bullet open open
up open us crazy topspin it's beautiful
paints the line and you're just like
that's good everywhere you just look at
it and he's every bit of six four oh
yeah fully his serve is disgusted his
serve must be those guys who are six for
six yeah I would their sir you're not
returning it no and then they put spin
on it yeah but he's professional he's a
professional athlete very different know
where I'm not okay we play with each
other all the time and it's a gift that
he's willing to play with yeah if I play
at my absolute best yeah he gets an OK
warm-up for an hour
Wow because and where'd you play where I
played in high school
to get out of PE he played a sport you
didn't have to it's a completely
different it's like me boxing yeah I box
yeah now if I box you I look good great
and then I get in with a guy who's just
a guy who boxes yeah we'll see you later
yeah no it's a speed thing the Shands
are not up I'm getting punched
oh you're going you're getting surprised
punch no and they're seeing everything
you're doing what what are you gonna do
jab yeah it's hilarious that bad one
time me and Kirk are hitting and we
don't play for points cuz why and so
we're just we're playing for the journey
of just hitting well and I'm I hit a
couple really good ones in a row and
then I really rifle one like a really
good one and Kirk as he's running to the
ball is yelling don't think you're
something you're not and short hop line
I don't even touch it
iced I'm laughing so hard I mean he can
you back me up so bad with a topspin the
other the last time we played I hit the
fence with my racket in my backspin
that's how far away from the board I wa
that's ridiculous it's wonderful what
I've played with sometimes a hit I pay
people that play with me oh yeah open
level players professionals yeah and I
look so good when they hit toward me
because I you know I work on it and I
can mimic I can mimic what tennis is
like dance were you if you watch it you
actually get that right I watch I dunno
why
Oh Roger Federer practice videos on
YouTube our little bet that's what I do
they are meditating well go ahead and
bring up Roger Federer
super slow-mo oh [ __ ] hand uh uh take
take a look at them I'm going to New
York to go to the US Open I'm gonna see
Roger Federer live and if you shoot me
in the head on the way out I've lived a
good life I know I know I is a gift you
know what a gift it is for us to be
alive during Federer Rafa yeah Djokovic
yeah the best the best it is advice for
all of them the best well this watch
this watch the post Kaminsky here I know
he's going to break this down go the
other one go the other one I don't even
know and I don't like I don't actually
like slow-motion when it comes to watch
watch look at the lag yeah his two feet
is rarely on the ground watches look at
this you're seeing one the most
beautiful things of all do look at that
it's a gift
we're we're seeing something we'll never
see again yeah well this is this is
balletic
his backhand is better than his forehand
and anyone who plays tennis knows that
is an anomaly this is the music I that's
like saying Merv two balls are more
useful than your dick during sex yes yes
your balls are more useful than yeah
that you're better at putting the dog in
the tub and you are [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] that's a great metaphor thank you I
mean he's not even doing anything
no he just he's just now making any
noise he going no no he doesn't make any
noise he makes noise rarely when he wins
the man bring up bring up no easiest
tennis players again Rafa's forehand is
a gift
no no he's incredible the topspin on it
is so good you want top five a lot of
sense about fun Neal Brennan directed a
commercial with Rafael Nadal and said he
was really nice
yeah yesterday I was playing tennis with
my girl and a guy was giving lessons
next to us and his noises were so
distracting she was like I've stopped
and I just hit against the wall that's
annoying he was like yeah yeah you're
not winning ah was he really good no he
was just a guy giving a lesson to
another guy he was good you know but
then he started giving lesson to a kid
and it would the talking was so much
that she was like I can't I can't do
this anymore
no I I feel shame cuz we got her a new
skirt and she look great so cute really
women's tennis outfits are so great
they're adorable they're adorable
they're not overly sexualized but
they're still great there are some hot
tennis players out there I said I told
her I said you look great and your game
is gonna get better and a lot of players
that's all they went on their entire
career mm-hmm yeah well I went watch
some satellite pros these women play and
they are that certain that's their job
they do that you know and it was in the
South of France where I summer at times
and we actually separate there I'm glad
you asked a number of times Michael
making a friend he has lots of money in
me down everyone yeah everyone needs one
of those you should have very wealthy
friends you need at least a couple cuz
those guys need people to hang out with
and people like us have the time we're
free during the day and they and they
fly you privately that my buddy my buddy
has private jets jeez and this is one of
my closest friends and I loan him so I
was 18 jeez yeah so when he comes to
Chicago to see me do my special right he
you call all your said special I do well
that's what you know what that's so
funny because the the critics do it and
I write their credit I call it just
original expression cider yes yes
chuckle monkey that was do you remember
is that still site I don't know that was
just where they had the list of open
mikes when I first started chuckle
monkey oh can you imagine and you'd go
to chuckle monkey calm and it would just
be like Monday this restaurant in San
Dimas it's not there
yeah that's where they had the open mics
yeah yeah well that depresses me
but I was an open mic er for men we all
were we all were until I mean now these
kids they got a billion of them they can
do two spots tonight of these open mics
we had to scrounge yeah I had to go to
the lawn to seize laundromat on
Wednesdays what do you think of the
state of comedy today strong strong over
examined over examined yes what does
that mean I'm tired of them talking
about comedy and talking about us like
we're poets and [ __ ] yeah god I agree
with that
we're not Allen Ginsberg we're bunch of
[ __ ] I [ __ ] agree we're a bunch
of clowns learn to greet us enough about
every subject to make fun of it and then
stop reading I agree you read more than
any comic I know I do
most of us borderline full-blown [ __ ]
I've said this well that you're you're
all awesome you are a classic example of
very smart and all the great things but
but um it's when we start taking like I
watched a little bit of I haven't seen
the show but I'm dying up here
god bless Andrew Santino and Eric
Griffin all my friends who aren't great
guys and I hope the show goes on forever
but the one thing I didn't watch it
because as a comic who's lived this life
yeah when they were talking about your
job is to tell the truth against all
odds and they're creating this sort of
like Perry yeah all right no I know but
I say this every time when the you know
we've seen a lot of comics get in
trouble and of course justifiably so and
whenever I read a lot of the stuff
they're like this person was anointed as
the is the top guy I'm like not by us
don't have those conversations now New
York Times NPR The Huffington Post you
dorks decided someone was the voice of a
generation and we're like what are you
talking about
they just transcribed their farts whoo
what are you doing read a real book
that's so true why are you doing this
commies job is to shed light on the
truth no no no you make me laugh
[ __ ] who percent of the time
yeah to Chris Rock hold him accountable
he's the guy Chris Rock tells you no I
say but Chris Rock Chris Rock is right
yeah almost all day like but the rest
like that it's not it's still not the
deepest like you get it you get it
deeper you're gonna get a deeper read on
things all things race if you read
tossing coats and then Thomas solo you
where you would never base your
knowledge on a single source you'd be it
more on it yeah yeah but you're pinning
down these people's like well they're
the voice of comedy what are you even
saying I'm so glad you're so what are
you even talking about I haven't had
anybody out articular there's so many
voices of comedy yeah and that's what's
great about it but its BV it's being
over analyzes let us just go to our joke
joke corner like idiots because that's
so hard well when you get on the road
the people are paying a lot of money to
see you make me laugh [ __ ] and
that's what they should demand yeah yeah
I'll try to say something my last
special I'm getting too old not to say
something I'm getting too old not to
care enough about I read too much not to
have a point of view right yeah yeah and
I try to let that sort of I do it
generally where I where I will comment
on the destructive elements of the
trending conversation ER so I'm gonna
that's gonna seep its way in yeah but
don't don't look to me I'm not your do
not stand there and and and think that
you are I always think like if I had a
special what would I call it and I think
I would call it this changes nothing
because it's just it's just I need to
figure I feel the same way about art
stuff I make like I'm just we're just
making things because the existential
crisis of being alive yeah is a lot yeah
and we're very lucky to be able to do
this as work yeah very lucky to be able
to even express ourselves absolutely do
that in China where I was just when I go
on the road sometimes or when you're in
different places and you end up in a
weird restaurant like I was working in
in Atlanta for like a few weeks and the
hotel I was at was like a corporate kind
of place where like business people
stayed and I'd go down to the lobby and
eat dinner and I would listen to them
talk about and they'd be having like
meetings and [ __ ] like dinner meetings
and I was like holy [ __ ] God yeah if
I think whatever you believe in that
that's not my life not saying that's a
shitty life but like I couldn't do it
well that's what happened to me is I was
working for a couple corporations and
including banks and I and I had family
who has worked in the corporate world
and I thought to myself I remember you
can have a good life and you can make
money and
and you work with good people and you
know that your life is fine it's good
but for me just for me because I'm a
weirdo this way mm-hmm I thought to
myself at the end of the day I'm trying
to move a product that that corporation
makes whether it's a financial
instrument something whether it's a
number of things but but I'm working to
further and trust that brand to to a
buying group to a buying populace yeah
and that requires toeing the line and
require strategy it requires all these
things and a lot of effort and thought
to get them to buy whatever it is that
you are selling even if you believe in
the product I don't care I couldn't care
and also at the end of my life it would
be a number yeah I don't know have I now
at least I have a diary yeah of all the
things I think about and probably as I
look back on my old stuff I cringe a
little bit because I was a nerd oh you
an older and oh my god I look at old art
and I'm like what so you do a lot of you
paint and stuff
yeah can we see some of your stuff sure
bring it up on my Instagram I didn't
know this about you at Kevin G Christie
I mean that's what I'm cuz you're a
legit comic as we know as I if you guys
don't know where are you gonna be are
you touring a lot of mom about to be in
San Jose with Whitney oh you are yeah so
there's my Instagram oh you're good
mostly some of my sketchbook stuff ones
okay Wow go back over to a better one
let's go through more I throw the grid
let me see the grid
I'll stop you it when I like I suppose
II go keep going keep going this is what
would you call this abstract er I don't
know see that one on the left the hello
everyone I like that one
that one took a while that's really good
but no this is what I went to who is
that that's really cool for this yeah
Wow I went to art school oh that's
that's legit [ __ ] right there yeah this
is what I mean I this is like I probably
spend more time doing this
do you sell your art I don't sell my
personal work but I work commercially is
I would buy that from you and put it up
and frame it I don't like the process of
selling stuff I don't enjoy anymore well
cuz it you'd but what would you charge
that exactly
I don't know it's really nice I don't
how long did that take you that took a
while like how long I would say 20 hours
and and you're considering everything
before you do it that one I had a plan I
actually did kinda did a version of that
one in black and white like earlier and
I was just like there was something
about it I thought was interesting so I
just decided to keep doing who is it
okay I will tell you the idea behind
this which no one would ever get in a
million years yeah but I like it I was
thinking about like that kind of selfish
set of parents that make their life way
too much about them even though they
have kids and they're the kind of people
that like scheduled vacation during the
Christmas holiday so they make you have
like another Christmas after Christmas
because they were in like the I totally
get that from that so they're like
showing up late in the Christmas trees
are already in bags on like the side of
the street and they're showing up to
their kids like ugly condo building
that's what the building is and they're
just like so fired up about themselves
like they're too into their clothes love
this they're just wearing the kind of
shirt that you see moms who are spiffy
and do their Pilates we're like and
she's got it tucked into her just like
very much if you extra you're to about
it like you're just you're living a life
you should have stopped living a long
time ago it's really good - nice it's
really good and dad is good he dropped
the president he's kind of beleaguered
but he's also part of the problem cuz he
never was like are we [ __ ] it's
great look at his hair yeah I mean I'm
I'm obsessed with I always find it
interesting about people that have can't
acknowledge what they've lost like they
you know there's hair styles are a big
thing where it's like you see a guy who
it's like a two paisa are the most
fascinating thing to me cuz they fool
quite literally no one then no quite
literally no one they fool through no
further it's it's like they think
someone is gonna watch a puppet show and
be like that's a real person like it's
impossible but yet there's still people
it alone true their pudding it speaks to
just like oh you're mentally weak yeah
so when you see or you just have no idea
you have no idea how you
come across to other people you see a
comb-over or just like weird plastic
surgery and you're like oh you just
don't you don't think you're enough
which I relate to 100% there's a million
reasons things I do accept it right I'm
the same way I'm not gonna go get I'm
not gonna go I'm not gonna pump myself
full of steroids in I'm 51 but I got
more muscular and yeah I mean I met I
remember someone was talking to me I
about wristwatches and they're like
maybe it was Joe Rogan and he was like I
don't care about wristwatches why do you
care I was like we'll fight a wrist as
wide as yours I probably wouldn't feel
the need to put something nice like it's
you know it's all compensation yes it's
all this but is it you try to stay aware
of it to where it doesn't become a
problem that's right so you know but
yeah that's no one would ever figure
that out just by looking at it but it's
it's excellent but no but when you say
that I get I get it all okay because
you're being really specific with your
with your painting I try to be I mean
that's all there any expression on our
face I that's all there is for me is the
process you know of doing it who are
your favorite artists who [ __ ] alive or
dead I don't care my favorites right now
Kerry James Marshall bring him up he's
this guy really threatened Doyle Hancock
is another full blown like weirdo Ripper
really trend all Hancock is right Kerry
James Marshall just had a show at MOCA
does the best thing I've seen in a
decade it was so mind-blowing I wish I
knew are this dude is on some other
level [ __ ] he's so rad they're huge the
one of the hair salon that one with a
pink floor on the top that one that one
in person is such a banger you're just
like oh alright dude you're you you
burnt it down you burnt it down you
burnt painting down a whole different
kind of guy right pull up Trenton Doyle
Hancock already grew up
I think Kerry James Marshall from
Chicago black Chicago probably poor he
had the scenario where he was like I
want I love nice art galleries and
museums in South Los Angeles oh really
yeah and now lives in Chicago oh that's
why but he has a great quote he goes I
love museums and nice galleries so I
just thought I should start making the
kind of paintings
could get into museums and nice
galleries that's how simple it was and
then he just like became a juggernaut
he's in our systems every trend Oh
Hancock is so rad
just like full-blown weirdo ripping I'll
get that man that guy is not those
things are huge
that's not like oh this will take a week
you don't even he doesn't even know one
of those guys get a painting
it's a lot trend Oh Hancock's Kerry
James Marshall is unbeliev inif you had
the money like good luck is that wealthy
he's well he's just he's I mean he's
going into art history so buying him is
like buying Apple stock 50 years ago
damn where it's just like no damn if
he's 250 grand for anything I love if
you get it you know that in 20 years
it'll be worth a million I I love that
[ __ ] but trendy Oh Hancock is even in
the high thousands I thought he was at
an Art Fair and there was like a drawing
I was like maybe I could I was like how
much stronger like 7 grand I was like
wow I did a I did a podcast with Sharon
Stone and I did her in her dining room
and I go who made those huge paintings
on either side of me she goes best cat
damn she she'd would take I think 10 or
20 percent of her income back in the 80s
and buy art that's what and she has one
of the she has an incredible organ with
Thurman maybe when she got her first big
modeling contract bought a Picasso took
all the money and just bought a Picasso
drawing and like there was just there
trying to I saw something on Instagram
or they're trying to get you to invest
in art through some service and they
were showing the the growth and it was
like the sp500 like two hundred forty
three percent over the last 20 years
master works four thousand process some
of that though is also because it's
inflated for sure yeah they well because
the brokers themselves buy it up yeah so
they were doing a corner market we're
doing that Warhol they were they were it
was [ __ ] brokers and millionaires
need the art they already own to be
worth a lot of money yeah so that's why
they get on boards of museums so they
can be like we need a Warhol show it's
like well that's because you own seven
walls and you need them to be worth a
[ __ ] ton of money really yeah
now now where do you stand on the on
Modern Art the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
stuff some of it I love some of it I
hate yeah it's like anything but how do
they get away with you know
they had arguing that much money
everyone's everyone's involved in the
lie everyone's in from the critics
to the buyers to the sellers to the
galleries to the museum they're all
getting money they are they're all
getting money so and they all need to
justify its existence otherwise why'd
you pay 250 grand for a critical theory
degree from Sarah Lawrence like you're
[ __ ] or like you need that to exist
it's like religion you need it to exist
as a thing
otherwise you're like what what are we
[ __ ] doing here like I'm there
selling a neon sign that said jungle
three times yeah in Chelsea for four
hundred and fifty thousand dollars yeah
and there was a there is a they were
selling a DVD of a of an abstract film
that was just images for a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars I don't mind it
because you're just taking advantage of
hedge funders I'm good [ __ ] yeah yeah
when you bought the Jeff Koontz
basketball containers you made these
things it's a water container koa oon
st0 no KO ons so it the basketball
containers its water with basketball in
it and it comes with a certificate that
says you can change the water in the
basketballs because the water molds in
the basketballs to sleep so you're what
did you buy oh you bought and by the way
if you think he built an inch of that
you are mistaken he doesn't touch in it
same with like all the big artists they
don't make [ __ ] they come up with the
idea they email it to someone if someone
executes sit really but and what does
that cost millions million millions is
probably reaction ten times millions and
millions it by the way [ __ ] you had four
million dollars and warranted by it
they'd be like I'm sorry there's a list
there's a waiting list [ __ ] cat Jeff
Koons yeah what a phony I love him he's
a vet but he was also he makes like he
made this Shih Tzu dog sculpture that's
like 50 feet tall out of flowers and
it's jaw-dropping I don't care that he
didn't make it
he made it happen with the Viper she was
weird-ass Fame and it exists but [ __ ]
Jeff Koons but let me see it it's so rad
these things right but huge you know
it's made of flowers flowers those are
amazing the big ones are amazing there's
a one at LACMA right now I don't care
because when you stand in front of an
enveloping piece of art that shit's real
you can't stand it for them like whose
[ __ ] if you stood him from that you
be like dude flowers this is bananas all
flowers yeah
and some I think it was this piece
someone was like you're clearly
discussing like a post 9/11 world where
and he was like no no I just thought
it'd be rad looking like a giant flower
dog that you know a giant flower dog
works let's is it's his artistic
instinct where he doesn't have to
question he just like it pops into his
head he's like that
same I mean that weird painting I'm a
just popped into my head and I couldn't
get it out so we're painting I guess I'd
better make it heard and it seems that
will work that took several engineers
yes yeah that is considered yeah deeply
so I buy into it and when I buy into
like not all of it but the the stuff of
it I don't find annoying I find lots of
performance out of knowing but some of
its super powerful
yes depends it's like any people well I
bet the but when you say depends I hope
I I contend that some of it is art and
some of it is not that's where I draw
the lines I don't say that any of its
not art some was just really bad art no
that's the difference is I say that some
of it and people when Jeff Koons does
that thing with basketballs and he's
taken advantage of his name he's being a
businessman and he's not creating art
he's [ __ ] taking advantage of morons
which he should rich morons or poorly
sure you know or people are just
investing because they know other people
are [ __ ] so it'll be worth something
later I don't know what it is but but
that's not art I don't there's a lot of
it their language to you art is like
things that require an innate talent
like drawing a sculpture I think that I
think like anything else art should
should be considered it should there is
there should there is criteria there for
good art and a criteria really for art
in general which which requires a degree
of honesty original self-expression
technique all the things that go into
the meaningful difference between
anything otherwise I could take every
time I take a [ __ ] every time and I
flush it down the toilet but I would
take a picture of it I go I just made
art today but there is by the way I put
myself this is a Marxist notion probably
I would put myself on the same level as
as your boy at Trenton delaying Cogswell
Hancock and I go I know he does his
thing but I do my thing and to me this
is art and I have a small group of
people and I would find them I would
find them they'd probably be we are
German I would only say there is an
inherent value in something that is only
beautiful because it creates a reflexive
experience that you kind of can't even
put your your finger on correct and the
Jeff Koons basketballs well I don't love
them on their way to becoming very
expensive they pass through and were
criticized by hundreds and hundreds of
people who are very very smart
yeah and it somehow got through that
system is there any because they're
because they're in on the lie to certain
degree thing they're not using this and
some of them they're lying to but I
think his lies the thing I like about
him is he's fun and he said he said he
because he was the art doesn't matter
it's the gesture yeah again hey Jeff the
balloon dogs though when you stand in
front of them they're big and shiny and
you're like [ __ ] yeah I did yeah that
looks heavy him yeah he takes a balloon
of Tweety Bird then has someone make it
out of cast iron
then they paint it all shiny and you
stand in front of me or like that shiny
hmm and it's good and then some dope
pays four million bucks for it well he's
a businessman he wakes up oh no he's a
he worked in like advertising before he
became a famous art there you go he knew
exactly what he was he's a very smart
marketing guy but so was Warhol I mean
some of my favorite yeah arguments in
the comedy store was me and of Davidoff
screaming at each other about Warhol Dov
hates Warhol in a way that's so I've
been with Dov I go to Modern Art [ __ ]
uh-huh and Dublin I do this is in Puri
why he's been one of my favorites of all
time he's great but like I would do this
thing where I would try to find very
traditional Warhol drawings and I detect
something like what you think is drawing
it's great I love it and I've just all
capped its Warhol you Mook and
[ __ ] is the best he's the best
[ __ ] this dog he left me yeah Warhol
was um was a real personality I think
it's
personality kind of but he figured you
can't I don't think you can discredit
someone who figured a thing out that
then caught on to a huge huge level so
something he tapped into the notion of
Fame and examining it was transcended to
a lot of people you could say is hanging
about porn no church has its own thing I
mean I never I I actually I think that
Warhol's important in that maybe he gave
other people license to be weird but
good mm-hmm you know what I mean like
there other people who are who thought
the world very differently were like
wait if he's doing that I I think what's
inside my brain would actually work
there are industries and people I kind
of consider lighthouses yeah and are
very important to perpetuating the
existence of weirdos
yes and where does the people of
alternative lifestyles that maybe don't
know it's okay and live in a place where
they're not exposed to it they see
things like the fashion industry or
Broadway or drag and they're like wait
wait those people are like me
dude that's why I always argue for
that's why I never back in the day I
never made fun of gay people or trans
people even when I was doing stand-up
because instinctually one I didn't want
to make anybody feel bad one I just knew
that it was how you were and yeah and
you were alone in the world and you were
definitely teased and I just never liked
poster boy I would use that difficulty
yeah yeah yeah but I also just didn't
like being the popular kid who happened
to be straight and white I did it a long
time ago in the [ __ ] 80s I was like
all right I'm not yeah I was like I
don't want I don't want to be the one
who takes the they're all laughing and
then there's that 3% or that one to
Dover there without one gal over there
who's gay or or dresses in women's
clothes whatever the I got arrested in
New York and I've got arrested sitting
next to a drag queen this guy who is
that's [ __ ] but he was a dude and I
go started talking to me cuz he I'm just
to do but you know like chicks but I
just like it doesn't like a broad
sometimes he's a real thick me and he's
a crossdresser or not whatever yeah
crossfader but but but the point is the
point is is that I've always I boy I get
older I really think that a culture
stays strong when it provides safety
for your weirdos I've recently in the
last couple months maybe three months
become obsessed with drag and it's saves
lives
I believe it you're talking about kids
that were going to kill themselves yes I
watch i've watched now every episode of
RuPaul's Drag Race
I have a favorite drag queen I went I
actually left my house paid to see this
person show it was jaw-dropping one of
the best things I've ever seen
yeah they give her you know as a comic
when you go to seize lemon like on
Broadway and you're like oh we're
[ __ ] we're doing nothing up there
like these people are singing dancing
and they're hilarious yeah you're like
oh it was like that where I was like
holy [ __ ] you are one of the chosen
people it's an art form and it is
because I watch the show I'm now like
rewatching seasons at this point it's
like the wired yeah and you see what
they go through to get there yeah the
stories you have to be heartless not to
connect with these people of course
pull up jinkx monsoon of course my
favorite and Rupe are doing this [ __ ]
group honk and the daily Paul has pushed
the needle nope no of the world in the
right direction for imagine the things
RuPaul's had to hear about himself over
the years I'll be honest I'll be honest
he did an episode of MADtv 23 years ago
yep and I remember I didn't know this is
my favorite queen dream jinkx monsoon
Wow Sync can sing you into a corner and
beat you to death really and one of the
funny like anyone we know funny for real
can write real jokes like funny for real
dude
I believe and the timing of the show
like they have this like musical partner
that the jinx works with and they have
all these originals it was jaw-dropping
today and in a lot of cultures he or she
or whatever would get he can he'll it's
beat up but considers put in jail
humiliated and considered a deviant yeah
like you know they would put something
on him like you you are a pedophile or
the others in Russia you're gay that
means you [ __ ] kids yeah and they'd
kill you jinx identifies his gender
non-binary
yeah and I'm here for it man I could
this show guy Branum was there too and
I was like that's one of the best things
I've ever seen in my whole life and I've
seen a lot of [ __ ] and I'm not an idiot
like I know where you in good
performance is and I was like this is so
good it made me mad that it wasn't like
bigger I was like I want thousands of
people to see all I did was call people
I knew with more power than me
quick Whitney instead I was like you
have to go see this yeah you have to
tell people about says it was so good
yeah it was that like it was
transcendent when art is that good it's
transcendent you're like this is good to
everyone it's a great that's a great
word for it well again it does it makes
your culture colorful it gives license
to other creatives don't think
differently who feel better when they
dress differently when they love manly
and that is actually how you make for a
strong culture it's actually if you want
a strong culture then that's what you
it's the same notion as spreading out
the gene pool
you have stronger groups of people when
you spread it out and it's the same
feeling you had the first time he came
to a comedy club when I arrived at the
Comedy Store or art school was like oh
[ __ ] felt like I was home yeah you're
like oh you guys are you people are like
oh [ __ ] I'm not I'm not the weird here
yeah holy [ __ ] it's that thing and they
are these people are so important to
young people who see the way like people
like Josephine Baker like black
performers jazz musicians used to feel
when they go to Paris yeah yeah they
were black in the United States second
classes and they go to Paris and they
were looked at his artists I said they
just they were like holy Sh I went to
Scandinavia with Whitney on tour and
every old theater which they're
shockingly beautiful they were like oh
you know Josephine Baker they have the
signs like like those jazz people you're
like well did Chet Baker played here no
like they were treating those people
with the respect they deserve
yeah way before us we're all like you
sit there and they're like I'm Charlie
Parker goddamn hit what's wrong well I
always think about I always think about
the great Louie Armstrong who would
there is a Jewish family in New Orleans
and New Orleans with your black you are
either a pimp you were a criminal or you
were a preacher I mean there was no
other you know
and or you know things didn't work out
for you yeah your or you are basically a
sharecropper I mean you know and Louie
Armstrong came from a very painful I
think it was called the fifth Ward they
called him the battlezone they called uh
something like that and he would he
would get on the this Jewish family in
New Orleans would hand out coal to the
families and he would ride that coal
wagon and he is a six year old even
younger would blow the bugle to let the
families know that the coal was here so
he would sit on the front and go from
like that I always think about the first
time I think it was Charlie black who
was a white southerner 16 years old and
always raised to believe that black
people were inferior yeah and and he he
listened to this man play the horn and
he said everything changed for him in
that moment he said hold on uh-oh this
doesn't make sense I was told that
mm-hmm that black people couldn't do
this but this guy's this guy and and
it's like it's like when Marsalis has
said the only way I can describe his
playing was it sounded it looked it
sounded like God must look something
like that
like it sounded like light yeah the kind
of light that comes from God and and the
same thing this sort of conversion
happened to Charlie black and he went he
was a seven boy at 16 England Oh
everything I've been told a lie yeah so
that's what a black person can do that
comes out of a black mind a black body
oh okay
and he became one of the lead lawyers on
Brown versus Board of Education when I'm
like 17 years old I used to I got a
private drawing lessons with this guy
I'd taken classes a place called kids
art and then the guy I really liked this
one guy Aaron Smith a [ __ ] great
painter still as teaches at that College
I want to and he left to cause he didn't
the job anymore and so I would go to his
apartment and Silverlake and get like
drawing and painting lessons this guy
was my [ __ ] hero
I dressed like him he had like cool
tattoos were like brown Dickies and
black t-shirts and like cool steel rings
like I literally just copied this dude
yeah I was like this is gonna be cool
this guy's my actual hero right
and then I noticed he has two girl
roommates and I've watched enough
Three's Company to know what's what and
I'm like I'm like which one of these is
your girlfriend and he goes neither and
I go are you gay and he goes do you
really want to know I go yeah he goes
yeah I was like okay and my friend
Travis went with me Travis had known him
since he was like 13 and Travis's head
almost fell off the body and butt and at
the same time I had been real I'd been
going to a lot of like youth group
Church Jesus stuff now at 17 you stopped
being able to go to a youth group like
the high school group you have to go the
adult Church so I started going to the
adult one I didn't realize I'd been
inadvertently going to basically the
Footloose Church and so I get to the
adult sermons in there basically like
gay people are gonna are the worst
they're gonna burn how I'm like no they
don't they teach you to paint and stuff
and they're super cool and they have
bitchin tattoo so I was like oh oh light
bulb yes is silly so where'd you grow up
La Crescenta California oh you look very
religious no no no I went through a
religious phase in high school like from
like 14 to 17 because and I when I look
back and I think I was so terrified of
like sex and like the people getting
drunk at parties that I was like I need
a solid excuse to get out of this yeah
and Jesus worked you think very deeply
and by the way you speak like somebody
who reads everything I mean I do realize
you do okay cuz I yeah I know something
[ __ ] I try I mean I try it's a book I
don't read as much as I read but I mean
I have to I was gonna I was like taught
listening talking about if this guy
doesn't read books I'm gonna buy that
this is not not making sense no I do I
do
yeah but like to read fiction no non
fiction nonfiction yeah nonfiction like
I why would I why do I want to hear
about something someone made-up
nonfiction unless it's like space [ __ ]
or wizards and stuff no non-fiction is
actually more important than anything
else and I I'm a guy who reads
nonfiction
I mean fiction is more important than
anything else okay so so so I read
nonfiction right but now i you know but
i also have read my share of fiction of
course okay
and the reason fiction is more important
than anything else is because number one
it allows you to really understand and
get into what it's like
to be another person okay so tallahassee
coats who I read everything by him
recent right and Thalassa coats is
criticized by many on the right and many
even on the left as being quote unquote
a race baiter he's reduced he's reduced
as we do in today's dialogue yeah yeah
he but he wrote a book called my
beautiful struggle which is about a
black kid growing up in West Baltimore
hmm I don't give a [ __ ] where are you
standing the political spectrum read it
from the perspective of a human being of
what it's like actually to be black in
that area of the world I'm gonna grow up
watching alright will be yet amorous you
oh you will be moved on a human level
doesn't matter if you're white black or
Chinese it doesn't matter if you're
Chinese from Beijing and you read
Tallahassee codes the beautiful struggle
to put all your political [ __ ] to the
side you will get a sense that you will
get a sense of what it is you'll go oh
[ __ ] if I was a human being and I grew
up in that skin and that part I would
have to contend with the same [ __ ] and I
would I'd have a very different but you
get it you build a compassion in you
that's important and a did deeper
understanding so when I look at the man
now I or when I look at a black kid now
South Central Los Angeles I feel at
least like I have a little bit of a
deeper understanding when you read his
other book which won a National Book
Award which was very controversial
called between the world and me which is
a letter to his son who's 15 and his son
after Michael Brown's killer hmm dick
didn't get convicted they did the police
officer he he looked at he looked it all
he said at the TV is 15 euros said I
gotta go
and Tallahassee heard his son crying and
his in his bedroom
Tana as he writes this this thing about
you know basically this letter of what
it is what it's gonna be like for you
for me to be grow up black what it's
like for you to grow up like and how
afraid I am and a powerless I feel to
keep you safe now there's an indictment
of white America there's talk of white
supremacy yes yes yes I understand it's
gonna make you feel uncomfortable made
me feel uncomfortable I disagree with a
lot of it all that stuff not important
what simple
it made me feel deeply yeah well as
matters that made me think also someone
hurts your feelings
there's a reason yeah and I said it to
Rogen I said read this and Rogen had
heard the criticism and sent me some
articles yeah and we had a really good
discussion about it because I said it's
to be read as a psalm as a song as a
poem as a piece of art you don't have to
judge it politically or with the damage
it's gonna do to the conversation no no
it has its own truth yeah I mean it in
in the time I've been alive what I
notice is firsthand experience tends to
be the Silver Bullet of prejudice every
like older white lady I know is so
excited about their first black friend
they make it work
yeah like they it's just a lack of
first-hand experience where I grew up in
La Crescenta no black people so all I
was talking about this my friend you're
the actor Steve Halle my best friend
Steve we met in seventh grade I love
Steve he's the best dude what's he up to
he is working on a movie right now by
the way I love that guy pull up his body
it's Steve's 240 Steve's Jack Vegas
strut that's another guy you don't want
to fight he'll beat the [ __ ] gives a
bear yeah he's a goddamn bear what'd I
tell you legit giant let let move can
move like a dancer oh he's a badge and a
plate plate plate I think he played do
you want basketball didn't you know not
do you want like junior by the way look
at him he'll kill you
no yeah you don't want to [ __ ] with a
Steve's a big he's a legit tough guy big
fists [ __ ] yeah yeah so that's my friend
Justin right next to him that's the one
who beat that that's the one I told you
about it was into jujitsu in like 92
it's jut I've known both those guys
since I'm 13
love-love Steve how big guys love a
nerdy mascot Batman Steve's a [ __ ]
stud and Steve is that's got the
intensity or the little guy also steve
is the weirdest person I've ever known
and I've known Bobby Lee for 50 dude
he's hilarious
oh it's easily steve is a [ __ ] I love
the glue you know what he is Steve's a
full-on nerd in that body and right in
height so he was he hung out with me
really been lifting and taking his
fitness to another low no he kicked it
into high gear at some point his whole
life he's always been able to get big
quick I don't know what it is he's just
one of those dudes
yes
crazy genetics yeah legit giant six
every bit of six four but he could yet
absolutely but he could have been cool
but he hung out with me our Vietnamese
friend Tron army and friend Pedro and
were in a hip-hop dancing crew together
that's not even really a joke and we
weren't it's so sincere it's sad never
stopped working by the way not always
works non-stop working beautiful need a
giant you need a giant with supplies
aren't sense of humor god I love that
guy I tried to get him to start doing
stand-up
hey he's he's always toyed with the
notion I think he's gonna try it like
maybe once is successful to understand
he's two six I mean I don't know but
abriel I remember it really the fact
that I did it and he didn't there was
part of him that was like wait the
pussy's doing this an argyle sweater at
The Improv and the guys looking at his
wife tell me his wife's name again Sarah
shine sarah shahi gorgeous my guy says
some tour and Steve goes hey you stupid
the guy kept looking at this girl guy
gets up guys big Steve gets up right in
the middle right in the improv it's
gonna fight right there and I broke it
up as I told the guy that Steve was a
cop when I like a decade ago I'm dating
this woman who's very very attractive in
time and David Taylor goes Steve and his
wife make people very cynical about
their chances whereas you and that girl
give people hope well he's been with
Sarah for a long time they got three
great kids
yeah yeah I forget why we're talking
about us look at that oh but also I can
see about this our exposure to
african-american culture only came
through TV so it's this horrifying
bastardized version it's either hip-hop
cop shows the news that is a very small
limited scope so until you go out in the
world and meet actual people from
different places or you read you haven't
know you read content poetic reflection
from a guy who's a gifted gifted writer
yeah if you reach more people who are
mad at you
you're dumb yeah because that's where
you find out what you did wrong man you
have to be open to learning you can't
you can't and I understand why people
are getting mad about that stuff they're
like I barely am paying rent here can
you stop bugging me about what I call
things like I'm Barry I just lost my
pension like I don't care how I like I
get concludes very true right the
difference between what black I notice
what a black audience laughs at and an
average of white audience laughs at and
it's different because I feel like like
when you get too esoteric the [ __ ] that
works in Canada with an all-white crowd
mm doesn't work with a black crowd in
Los Angeles because they tend to be
dealing with things that are more
tangibly they also know how much they'll
be offended yeah like they're like we're
dissing small [ __ ] weak how you've got
your small [ __ ]
are you insane yeah like it's just but
you don't I like Latin audiences I feel
like they're there they do really hurt
for Felipe and they were so I I get on
stage I cannot I'm on stage for ten
seconds doing the front rows this dude's
not funny I had barely started talking
and I was like I'm going to definitely
get funny but he had decided look what
cuz you look super white nerd
yeah and they did they're not they're
not cuz you got your glasses on here
they're not they're not gonna right away
I think it's so culturally different
maybe I meant for me I [ __ ] love
Mexican audiences maybe because they're
more fun than me and I'm not fun you are
you're hilarious no but that's not
necessary get on you get any audience
yeah that I don't I'm not mad that they
don't like me there they get a vote man
they can hate my guts so [ __ ] I mean
come on yeah but if you have to open up
your whole scope you have I mean I never
I hadn't watched a minute of RuPaul's
Drag Race and my girl was like I really
like this show and it was like it was
like a final watching episode of Real
Housewife goddamn it and I watched one
she's like I'm gonna show you this
episode and it's the every season they
do a version of snatch game remember the
little game show and she's like I think
you should see jinx on snatch game I was
like what are you even talking about I'm
doing this because we're in love and I
watch it I'm like who the [ __ ] is that
yeah and why are they so good and jinx
is also narcoleptic which is hilarious
like the whole thing
in the in the old season this is five
years ago when the season aired it's a
pink one five years old this shows been
on ten years just jinx whispers to
himself before his critiques water off a
duck's back water off a duck's back and
I was like you I've met my sweetie
that's my girl forever holy and and then
I just kept watching and if it's one of
those things where they're so skilled
you can't not be impressed yeah let me
give them like a day they're like make
an outfit in the theme of this and then
they do it you're like I can't sew a
[ __ ] stick and they make it
themselves out of them do some so some
door I just started watching drag race
Thailand
it has subtitles which are tough but all
of them are crap they can make anything
and the idea is what at the end they
just try to execute these challenges and
the ones that do the best move up and if
you win the show you become a massive
drag star and you can make a [ __ ]
killing oh I bet I mean these were
selling out what is the what what are
the challenges the challenge is are will
snatch game you have to pick a celebrity
and impersonate them and then they judge
you on how you do so like jinkx did
Little Edie from Grey Gardens which by
the way what the hell kind of choice is
that I don't know what that is little
you've never seen Grey Gardens no it's
Jackie Onassis I believe cousins who
went bankrupt and live in this
dilapidated mansion I've watched if it
was years ago
it's great and they're so weird one of
them goes bald from being straight she
played her Little Edie and everyone's
like are people gonna know who that is
RuPaul's like are you worried that
people she's so good at it she wins she
wins the challenge yeah because she
nails it so are damn it's so that the
show is so fast thing to me because
they're so interesting and skilled and
talented now I find hilarious
you have to it's required reading as far
as I'm concerned you're not and it's
it's it's a cliff you know the same
thing we were talking about it's the
same value you get from reading fiction
yeah
you you will get a you will get you will
become more compassionate less
judgmental and ultimately smarter
ultimately you will deepen your
understanding which i think is [ __ ]
important as a figure one your old man
for anybody who's young listening but in
the body you understand is I have a
great body well if I thinks you've never
did to me you've walked up to me in the
Comedy Store in your shoe man you just
whispered you may have the most
beautiful body I've ever seen
ah well my body my skin took a beating
in [ __ ] Beijing oh yeah you wanna
what's what I've never and I don't have
a huge desire to go to China India China
is China Beijing is an industrial city
yeah yunjin where I shot which is two
and half hours outside of Beijing so I
didn't even go to Beijing yeah well I
got to Beijing I thought I would see the
Great Wall I'll see the inner city took
you to them now of China now you're
gonna drive two hours yeah you're gonna
go to this and China has been built up
to the level the sky the skyline is not
I don't know how to say not as God
intended it it's it's um China has had a
very traumatic history for sure
China has suffered from colonial
domination China decided that they were
gonna modernize and that was never gonna
happen to them they suffered terribly at
the hands of the Japanese they they were
forced into buying opium from the
British in the opium wars they had to
sign a hundred year lease and give the
island of Hong Kong to the British and
that extended to 1997 yeah
they suffered terrible famines under Mao
Zedong they suffered terrible purges and
you know massive restructuring of their
societies where whole seconds that the
population were forced to move into the
countryside the individual in China the
individual is not know is not the is not
of importance the way it is in the
United States Western is very hard to
understand but but at the end of the day
if you have a neighborhood and they want
to build a bullet train through that
neighborhood yeah you are not getting in
the way of that no you're you're gonna
move now and your your neighborhood will
be razed and you will be put in that
high-rise over there yeah so the Chinese
have been through a lot yeah
so the idea of personal serenity or hey
don't build that over there because
you're making the air
yeah you're polluting too much alike now
[ __ ] you man the Chinese said
productivity by the way by the way I am
in no place to comment on Chinese
history culture I've done my reading of
it I have my respect for it but but or
even Chinese mindset so I'm saying this
as somebody who went there I went there
in 1985 I'm there now
I spent very little time there I saw
nothing but it's it's [ __ ] it's at
all it would be a tough place to live
yeah it is polluted yeah because of the
amount of emphasis on production they're
using the most cement of anyone in the
world it's so roading the oceans because
you need sand it makes you [ __ ] much
yeah and they they've also decided
though in one year they went from coal
to gas like everybody China moves fast
China goes hey yeah we're not using coal
anymore everybody's using gas yeah and
now they're moving to nucular so they
will clean the era yeah China the
Chinese will clean here up faster than
anybody else there is a thing we do in
the westernized world we're like hey hey
hey you're trying to get not poor too
fast and they're like oh really yeah we
have the Internet we see how you guys
live [ __ ] you man and you don't think I
want to Starbucks on every corner a side
you don't think I want a cake pop yeah
like decide also don't tell me how to
live my life two Chinese had to deal
with that for hundreds of years yeah so
so there's a great deal so whenever you
talk about these trade wars this trailer
has been going on forever and those
trade wars were never in the favor of
the Chinese so you know the Chinese were
forced into treaties that made no sense
for them whatsoever yeah the Chinese
didn't have a right to
self-determination so you know once they
got their independence and they become a
superpower you're not telling them what
the [ __ ] to do there's a real problem
with like artistic copyright
infringement because they they don't
have the notion that it matter like I
don't give up yeah well that's another
whole nother like I I'm a real policeman
for like the stealing of people's art
and like yes especially like old skate
graphics being stolen and stuff like I
get really bummed about that [ __ ] and I
try to alert people yeah and I alerted
this guy was like they're definitely
ripping his eye he goes yeah I can't do
anything about the China thing but you
know they pay a price that took is
conformity conformity you you are told
there's a there's a pamphlet when you
should have filmed their do not do not
say anything bad about the government
you are not here to be political new and
you will be asked to leave or
incarcerate yeah yeah so you do not get
up with a placard in China when you go
and I went to the Forbidden City the
lines way too long but when you go there
at Tiananmen Square way too crowded but
when you lie about going to you're like
now yeah it was sold out I was like oh
good I'm out of here but but when you
you you do not you do not as a Chinese
person get up with a a placard and say
equal rights or whatever it might be you
will disappear you will be taken off the
street by the authorities yeah and who
knows
I'm sure you'll be I'm sure you person
standing in front of take in Tiananmen
Square you know who they can't find that
dude that's true they do not know where
that person nowhere is they haven't
known for quite a while that's right and
that's the way it is well when you have
that kind of conformity it's very
difficult to become and they're not
there's a reason that you're not going
to be that creative you're gonna be good
at mimicry but there's a liability to
any society that puts conformity and
order above you know disruption which is
art which is creative there's a certain
amount of importance to destruction
there's I mean I grew up that's called
animation Punk and there's a certain
there's something important about like 9
now [ __ ] that let's burn it down nearly
yeah it's like it's like the forest yeah
you it helps grow and the Chinese do
that but it's a top-down kind of burn
yeah they want a really man on a board
when you see these like sky rises and
you see these they they like there are
10 buildings the exact same building
that people have to live vertically and
yeah they're crazy look and they're cuz
I got to do something with all the
people but but there is something so
numbing about that like there's
something about for sure that that's
been planned on a board by bureaucrats
who don't know you know nothing about
the area I mean when you and from a
financial standpoint like our next stock
market crash is already on the calendar
like they have that they're like no no
we'll wait till 2022 like I mean they're
they bottle our debt decades yeah they
giggle at this tariff [ __ ] yeah
there it is
look at that ya know you see that all I
think his name is it out look at that
that photographer
my character when took these amazing
pictures that I want to say it's Kirksey
maybe and they're the same ones in like
Brazil to where you're like there's
something wrong with that yeah I mean I
I feel the same way about any bigs I
mean I think New York City is it just an
New York went do that and it's humanism
gone wrong it's an ant farm well in the
new year and in 50s and 60s there the
idea under Robert Moses was flow is more
important than so they tore down these
beautiful old and inspired structures
and they built these huge monoliths they
did that in the South Bronx South Bronx
was neighborhoods and they put all these
poor black people etc into these giant
high-rises and then they lowered the
bridges even the buses couldn't get in
you feel like a [ __ ] yeah I don't I
do you have one night when you go into
Lake of the forest you get that feeling
where you're like oh wait this makes a
lot of sense an old-growth forest well
you're in the northern yeah I I had to
shoot a commercial in like Northern
California and there's Santa Rosa and
there was a tree near where we're
shooting that was a thousand years old
and I'm walking by I look at humongous
it says it's just gigantic right and
there's like don't touch the tree and I
was like here's the thing I'm going to
go touch this just feels different does
I went up I put my arms around the tree
and I went you've been here a long time
long time bro you've seen a lot of stuff
yeah you're gonna be here a long time I
waved on way way before the you know I
was just like I'm glad to meet you buddy
did you ever hear the expression who
said it to a great tree like that to a
great to the great sequoias everyone is
a barbarian mm-hmm everyone is a
newcomer and a barbaric again ever
will you writing it down on what paper
you [ __ ]
that's how you feel when you go to
Florence or those cities that have were
planned by a king and a pope back then I
went around the human beings I want you
in Italy a few like like a year ago
almost and like when you see that I mean
when you said but it's I can look right
now trial I get the same feeling
standing in front of certain works of
art that I do in the forest I think I
mean I've always thought big abstraction
is artists trying to compete with the
feeling you get in
you stand in front of a big expansive
color you're just trying to create that
same thing that vibration you get when
you're in the forest you're like oh wait
a minute yeah I'm I'm or I'm in earth
right now as opposed to a box yeah and
it but when I was in Italy I when you
see certain works of art you're just
like are you yeah look at that you gotta
go do that man you've gotta go to the
forest and touch a tree like that but
now if you're not impressed by that
you're wrong you're wrong right if you
see there's certain things that are
transcendent like the Pieta the david
certain these cathedrals are like what
the [ __ ] were you guys on back then you
guys are on some other level Sistine
Chapel can I can I get Suman on that
woman who's naked there's three I saw
the Sistine Chapel sure and I obviously
loved it but in Florence Michelangelo's
painting of Madonna and Child that [ __ ]
very well i braiding and you I could
tell I was like oh I can tell right now
why he's better than everybody else yeah
it's the elbow
it's her elbow let me just bring that up
everyone else is very well everyone else
at the same time not are they all but
the elbow stuff it's in here because
it's easier drugs you can't get a model
he didn't have a camera you can't get a
model to hold her elbow out that for any
amount of time so that means he was like
any old robot he nailed it right away
like you're like oh he's better he had
in the same way didn't he go to the
morgue and touch right the circular one
yeah no no no the other circular one
sorry that one you son that one look at
the help look at her elbow at the same
time people they would have had it
tucked in because the model can hold the
pose longer yeah he just was better and
by the way the fact that he was just
better than people that were around at
the time Raphael [ __ ] Leonardo da
Vinci is jumped yeah I thought you were
talking with something else I don't know
this this is it's not one of his this is
what they use as proof that they should
that they were right to clean the
Sistine Chapel that he liked painting in
bright colors was it clean the Sistine
Chapel it was bright as [ __ ] and they
didn't realize it was you know hundreds
and thousands of years of smoke from the
candles they put this like brown layer
on top that made it look kind of sepia
and kind of dark and moody it's like no
he wanted to look like that
but he I mean I stood in front of that
thing for look at the folds of her dress
yeah it's look at that I stood in front
that for 25 minutes and it was as
interesting as watching anything on TV
I've ever seen I believe it it was but
I'm get thee how does he get the
clothing to fold like that that's a
painting and but not for nothing the
paintings hard I can look at most
paintings and be like I can figure that
out now the Pieta the sculpture of Mary
holding Jesus bring that up looks like
it's raised [ __ ] that's what I
that's the one I was talking you look at
that and you're like okay where'd you
start in the corner do you draw on the
block but as a kid I remember seeing
that because I went my uncle lived in
Rome who is he
VI eta we'd go to the different parts of
Italy in that that thing that's so
powerful I remember this it might be the
greatest work of art of all time in my
opinion I remember this so well cuz he I
remember as a boy why looking at this as
a boy and looking at his body like his
put his he looked so pathetic and dead
and she look at the whole flesh on the
armpit were the fats coming up crazy it
lets out a stone burn the marble he's so
brilliant if Mary stood up she'd be
seven and a half feet tall yeah but who
needs her to be big it's like he knew
when he does the David he made the head
big see new people are gonna be looking
up at it wow this guy well that's her
baby was I don't even know how you
quantify that level of understanding
intelligence and talent at that time
based on the available information he
had access to how do you even figure
that you figure it out because we
haven't figured out that we haven't
figured out anything more the pyramids
it's the pyramid but it's also it's also
you're looking at a human experience of
a mother holding her child you're
looking at sorrow yeah you're looking at
meta sorrow there okay so so so so so so
that is not that's when you look at that
that's the pain of the world right every
mother has held their child like that
everybody who dies has absolutely all
its stuff that goes on there but but but
there are certain things that the
ancients knew and that we've never
improved on yeah we're good at getting
our bodies somewhere faster mm-hmm we're
good at being able to talk to each other
when we're in China and
and York we're good at pushing ourselves
beyond our biology so I have a sickness
and I can kill something in my body sure
we probably smell better because we have
so general things we were more
nutritious that'll shed Renaissance
smells were probably probably pretty
tough wolf yeah yeah but blah blah blah
right so so yes to that stuff but about
the human the human thing as far as
tapping into our game and they were all
they were there homing in correct like
that that they were connected and by the
way enacted this guy is is making that
piece about a woman holding her child
and he's essentially by all accounts a
gay so he's tapping into the female
experience of motherhood yeah in agony
and the ecstasy I think he was even
talks about Beatrice that was it was who
knows which is why his girlfriend you
don't think he's smart enough to change
a name in a diary come by his house I'm
walking down the street I go this
building looks significant I look up the
address it's where he lived while he's
making the David I'm like so wait a
minute oh you're telling me in that room
he was like that [ __ ] now I'm gonna put
the Hat [ __ ] like goddamnit like all
pissed about it I was like are you
that's when I see something where
something happened I'm like are you
[ __ ] the legend is he would go to the
morgue and feel the dead bodies well
that's why if you look at the Sistine
Chapel all the women just look like
dudes with implants because you couldn't
get female models so the women are
muscular they're big they're big armed
it's cuz he was just changing them to
look like women oh wow he did he I mean
it sounds so dumb like Merkel Angela was
so good but when you really look there
it's almost the modern art doesn't want
to talk about it cuz it just would lower
the prices of what's being made now I
remember there was an article was like
why does this guy cost as much as T up
below and it's just come on
he's look at him but there's one of the
guys at the bottom was this guy who
worked for the Pope the guy I think his
face is coming off and he would give
Michelangelo a hard time all the time
he's like yeah you [ __ ] that we got
to do this change they get more time so
he painted him as this like disgraced
dude well people are rosy he was under
he was the meta cheese that the family
at the time yeah they they paid
the commission money and art cannot be
separated for the most part unless
you're talking about me in which there
is very little I don't like for this
camera that's tiny dicks well what are
you gonna do put a giant shlong at
church
yeah well they got these great bodies
and let's see it let's see a dick on the
guy you know a lot of men have my word
ya know they're I mean David a very tiny
[ __ ] I know but you know it was tasteful
that's just keeping it on the air that's
just keeping it on the air you don't
want to scare people
yeah but I want I want a heavy piece oh
no I need one I don't I don't wanna I
mean it's like when you watch
pornography if the guy's not packing I'm
like what am i watching here except do I
go to the playground and watch pick-up
basketball no I watch the NBA I want to
see people fight with the right
equipment god damn right yeah well we're
gonna watch a war one one sides got
rifles the other side's got rocks like I
don't watch this one-sided next I need
to believability let's see let me look
at that look at that little thing yeah
that's strange it's strange it's no
there's no way as accurate the guy
laughs sighs they didn't they took him
off oh yeah all right
well well look at that touching God I I
had to go back I'm touching yeah that's
God that's the creation of man yeah I
think I have to go back and look at one
of the printouts I'm almost positive one
of them one of the paintings it's a
woman her thumbs on the wrong side I'm
almost convinced I have to go back and
look through it again
but I look I'm looking at it I'm
standing it on the floor looking at what
I'm liking that lady's thumbs on the
wrong side look at that he's in a womb
it looks like God by the way that's a
fresco you have to paint color into wet
plaster it's awful didn't you go blind
painting I don't think so I think the
paint was dripping in his eyes yeah but
it wasn't no I mean there's that's a
little bit of a legend he had so he had
a little bit of yeah I mean but again
dude what have you seen this better than
there's nothing we have to ignore its
greatness because it makes us feel you
guys didn't know that we were gonna be
this is gonna be a hard hour they
haven't christened I did are you
learning something chin I'm learning a
lot
III everyone should just try to engage
with art if you don't you're missing out
yeah it's like not listening to like
arts the cornerstone of a culture it's
what we point they say it's not a
culture it's not who someone said it's
not nests
sorry but it's like I forgot the other
word this is my you don't wanna live
with this is my issue with Dagestan
we're Cubs from the president basically
you know MMA is everything and all the
kids you know if you want to get ahead
in the secret services and they army and
cultures like that that put that much
emphasis on one thing are not doing the
right thing well I don't you know I
haven't I haven't raised a hand in
violence in over 30 years I mean on the
inside like you shove your way around
[Music]
walk into a saloon here comes the Shover
they're like Ivan Christina quiet but
like I watch whenever I'm at the Comedy
Store and there's that fight on an MMA
fight it's fascinating to watch and if
you're not fascinated by your kind of a
dummy [ __ ] some fights this weekend
what was the truth the two guys who
hated each other blond guy TJ Dillashaw
and Cody Garber and then you watch
Dillashaw proved himself to be for the
first week on spire for the first minute
you were like oh [ __ ] this guy's doing
all right this could be a real fight and
then the other you it was one thing for
like that guy has that other guy's
number and it may never change well TJ
Dillashaw is a his fight IQ like like
Demetrius not Johnson their fight IQ is
so high and what I mean by that is first
of all first of all there's nobody more
competitive than TJ and nobody
it seems who comes alive more when it
really counts and those championship
fights true champion he this marriage
between him and Duane Ludwig as' is
there creating a work of art you want to
talk about art when you watch that guy
fight he's so unorthodox it's just a
work of art and and the TJ is a guy who
can adjust even when he gets hit he can
adjust in milliseconds he comes
everything
TJ is bring up a picture of me and TJ I
mean it's ridiculous it's yellowed on
your just probably I'm Instagram I don't
know where it is but I mean I don't a
kid we did it nicely lightweights so
that's like he won he fights a 135 I am
so much bigger than he is at you Atticus
well I thought nobody realizes there's a
fire in a bar you're a little drunk
there's there's me there's me yeah you
see this guy you think yourself I said
the Brendan I go I go I mean he seems so
small oh yeah he goes how do you want to
lose like how do you want to lose no
that's what would happen if I try to
fight him it would just anybody my size
he he's he's such a nightmare
he's so good that's what I love they
figured out that Cody was would drop his
right when he throw his left I think
that's what it was and and so they just
worked on that and it's one thing to
work on it but Cody's fast as [ __ ] and a
really good fighter in a really good
boxer of course but he was just able to
drop his head he would dip his head way
to the left and bring that that right
around but this is everyone to me the
the nightmare at every bar you have
three I don't drink but you have enough
to where you're a little you're not
paying you're not in your right mind you
see this guy he bumps you an accident
you're like hey [ __ ] watch where you're
going and you decide to pick a fire then
he's smaller than you and then he's like
listen he's like do you don't want it
I'm gonna let you out of this and he's
trying but you're being an [ __ ] yeah
and then you're like let's do this and
as you lift as I lift my slow labouring
poorly aimed fist he hits me 15 times he
just in the kidneys he doesn't even [ __ ]
with my face he's like the cops he does
what he wants it it depends maybe he
grabs you and chokes you unconscious you
probably threw out my wrist and do
something where he's like you don't I'm
trying to help you please yeah yeah well
first of all you wouldn't hit him cuz
he'd just be no I wouldn't commit a
ninja
yeah this is a speed that's what Apple
it's also like he's also he's also knows
where to place his body that's what
people who don't fight I think like I
don't know how to fight and what I what
non fighters don't realize is there is
such thing as just being tremendously
good at punching it's like being good at
hitting a ball or throw it with him it's
where you're punching from like for him
for DC you thought about transcending
it's more than fighting with him and
that this this thing that he's doing is
I'm telling you it's it's art it's
[ __ ] that's you can't you think Bruce
Lee all those guys go [ __ ] yourself
that's that's when you open yourself to
other experiences you start to enjoy a
lot of [ __ ] you had no idea like my
girls always like I had no idea you're
gonna like it this much I was like oh no
next year we're gonna go to Provincetown
because it's like a big it's like drag
Lollapalooza every year and I'm going
and I'm gonna watch like 30 drag shows
gonna be epic yeah cuz you're looking at
something different
well what's fascinating a lot to me it's
like it's unlike a anthropological level
where you're like this is this is this
matters it's something that matters and
will matter to like the human race the
progression of humans and how they
behave and treat each other yes it's
it's also like a cliff notes to
lifestyles that a lot of people are too
lazy and annoyed to want to do the
reading like you're like I don't I don't
know what I'm supposed to call you
really we'll just watch the show it's
entertaining and funny and you'll learn
a bunch of [ __ ] you learned all the
bright all the right verbs and whatever
to call the pronouns to call each other
oh yeah that reminds you peppermint
peppermint peppermint one of my favorite
queens and it's a trans woman and like I
have peppermint like I have references
to what people are talking about now I'm
like no no it's like this like a gender
non-binary like jinkx monsoon like it's
just things you learn how easy er when I
watch it it's so good I try to get
everyone to watch it and it's so fun to
talk about as soon as I walk into the
Comedy Store
Justin Martindale makes a beeline to me
so we can talk about the last episode
how's he doing it's good dude he's he's
funny right now
I was watching him the other day
hilarious but on stage he seemed soaked
he was with the control was great he's
amazing he's it was like he was like no
you're at my show right now and a
handsome [ __ ] and the salad on that kid
that is a head of hair I would kill a
homeless person funny
dude just a fun guy to be around but him
Jayde they know I'm super into it so
they just go right to me they're like
what do you think about Aquarius less
look and I'm like here's what I feel
about it cuz I to me I love dissecting
it it's so interesting why someone wins
a challenge what their look was like why
the outfit was the way it was was the
lip-sync on the level what my favorite
thing in the world on the show is
sometimes it the people that are at the
bottom of the challenge they have to
lip-sync against each other and every
blue moon - people don't do the song
justice and RuPaul sends him both home
he does yeah he's like double sashay and
it's very rare and it is a kind of shame
put on these people he's like both of
you sashay away and you're like oh god
yeah so when you're exiled you're told
the sashay sashay away you either Shante
you stay which means you're still in the
competition or you sashay
and he doesn't have loves he always used
he always tells the person who doesn't
goes tells him you are amazing now you
get to go like show the world what you
are but it says now sashay away and
every once in a while
two queens phone and in and he's like
get the [ __ ] off my show and he sends
them both out and every time the rest
guys like oh because it means like don't
[ __ ] do that like how dare you don't
disgrace the house I built through some
of the most hundred should I've had to
deal with my whole I built this floor
you do not do this it's raising a double
specially in is he always trust like not
now he goes into the workroom to tell
him about challenges he's you see
dressed in a very beautiful suit he's
also very tall yes I mean in drag he's
oh I was losing him you're on MADtv what
an honor and I didn't know who I was
dealing with yeah and he was very polite
and very kind of like kind of like
together but I I'm not gonna say I had a
judgment on it I just I just thought I
was afraid of him a little bit because I
thought he'd probably think I was uncool
anyway and I just like how that drag
[ __ ] and I also looked at him as a drag
queen and I looked at him as kind of
like the lower rung of culture made yeah
I had a judgement I didn't know her I
didn't know him I didn't know who he was
I didn't know the significance of who I
was dealing with yeah I didn't know
anything so I I remember I regret not
having cornered him and gotten we're
talking about someone who in the world
of drag is basically irreplaceable like
I think about this all the time like who
takes the mantle after he's gone
there's really no one right now who
could oh she Angela one of my favorite
queens that one on the left with the
little afro shangela fantastic Quentin
great Queen right there so funny great
lip syncher great dancer alright let's
go to some Kevin's [ __ ] do some Kern
goddamn offense I spend I spend money on
this stuff I love it also the best is
Leslie Jones got into it just after I
did and is watching episodes that are
five years old and live tweeting him and
basically reigniting these feuds that
have long been squash and these poor
drag queens are now being like at
replied because Leslie's like your be
an [ __ ] like I was five years ago
please Oh God like she's coming at like
the the enemy of my favorite Queen was
this Queen Roxxxy Andrews and Leslie
it's just like you're just [ __ ]
jealous and rocking like we I'm patently
clear these are reruns brothers channel
13 early she's five years behind
it's so [ __ ] great oh yeah we deal
about it all the time I'm like all stars
to move worried I haven't seen Leslie
she's in New York Oh Leslie I talked
about her success and God bless she's
such a good person she was always a
great person and a murderer and a
murderer and a great person and and then
to see her success come now you know
what I mean she what a joy person man
what a joy always good always cool
always great to people always hase t'v
never an ass are always a good / like
never always had something good to say
up to everybody always just walking
around like a good person and and got it
Alyssa Edwards great Queen right next to
Lester there Alyssa Edwards alright
alright let's go to current events
look I'll turn this into a drag podcast
oh um hey I love it too bad Brendan's
not here he probably watches it giant
moth oh yeah tell about this
did Josh baseball yeah so you're a
sports guy - a little bit I mean I love
to me that the baseball is beautiful
yeah - baseball tennis it's the
beautiful sport yeah it's beautiful to
watch
I love that it's low what bug flew in
the ump ear and Moskva he had to go into
the dugout it flew ndon not only just
his ear like deep in where he needed
help he'd help getting it out what it
got scared let me see by the way we
could sample it are you having no very
little information about the lives of
umpires where's that show yeah where's
that scripted show but I'm gonna be very
that's when I'm all on see it pulls it
all right there and then the guy holds
it and it's still flapping it's still
flapping it's like a champion he wants
back in he's not done let him back
onstage
so weird weird be funny that flew back
into is here yeah alright yeah that's
weird
there bugs there are bugs it'll legs and
your skin Oh gross
yeah you know that right the new guinea
worms by get I got ravaged by a spider
the other night woke up to date multiple
bites how do you know as a spider
because when you pull if you pull the
whoopsie so you get a red bump right
yeah
stretch it out to make it lighter you'll
see lots of little bites Oh spiders they
get trapped to try to get away from you
oh so so it looks like one big - I've
been bitten by something spirit so you'd
like you look where's where's the
current I can't find it but like if you
pull it apart you'll see like smaller
bumps
that's usually a spider damn to my
understanding that's gross yeah yeah
panic I mean my house right now system
it's like a bug Haven but it's my fault
I let him live there because I like
because you raised bugs well there's a
skunk that lives under my house and cube
so I let it stay I'm not trying to get
out of there I see yeah I would just be
nice to it don't get it right yeah yeah
you see the next current event sure what
you guys Mighty Ducks fans at all the
the Disney Mighty Ducks oh this guy dude
that that mug shot is rough I did not
expect him to look like that
no remember this cute little kid from
Mighty Ducks I thought it was fake that
was fake it's like that guy's sprinkling
meth on his food and then smoking the
meth afterwards he's 37 what I think 37
years old that's like how Alex Jones is
44 you're just like nah Sean Weiss
arrest of the public intoxication fame
fame is a dangerous thing it's a toxic
element man and if not handled correctly
if given to this is that saying if you
want to ruin someone's life give him
Fame and money in her at a young age
fame early man is a toxic element very
few people make it out what did you just
got any drugs obviously yeah don't look
at him yeah 60 that's a 55 to 6 year old
man like you see him on cops he's the
one lying about huffing spray paint I
mean like were you huffing paying the
guy goes no and then he goes you have
paint all over your mouth and he goes
I've been huffing bang Sean Weis yep
never starve and I hope he gets it
together yeah well he's enemy teeth yeah
look at that mouth structure that's no
teeth yeah yeah definitely some missing
had his chest that's just you you became
a wretch did you see the picture of
smalls
from the Sandlot where guys wearing the
shirt that says you're killing me smalls
and he sees the most treat him as
friends they go let's get a picture it
guy has no idea why he wants the picture
no that's pretty great
that's the the big chubby the redheaded
ooh yeah I see him at the market
sometimes he all bunched up he seems
fine I think he's on a show right now
I'm like Netflix oh he's done all right
you see Frankie that's I root for
painful things when former child stars I
root for them cuz we John Emery nervous
yeah it doesn't end well for a lot like
Maureen Corey Corey Haim was the other
one
Corey Feldman that guy's just creepy I
went to a party at Corey Feldman house
when I was 17 and he was a sweet sweet
guy there's a sweet guy yeah but you get
you get dragged into him I believe
everything that guy says about what
happened to him I believe yeah he's not
stupid look at his performances in those
movies he's obviously a smart dude who
could do his makeup guy just strange
that that's it I'm not saying about
about him I just when I look at what
Hollywood has done to people yeah like
they just they're just aliens they're
just different well no you can't you
can't give all of yourself to to
Hollywood because eventually they throw
everyone away he doesn't I always say
Fame doesn't actually exist it's not a
thing now fame is doing heroin man if
you buy into it you're a [ __ ] try it
whatever but don't make it a lifestyle
otherwise you're your host it ends it
ends no weird who who's managed to use
Fame the right way their whole existence
you know unable to just they'd like a
guy Johnny Depp who's been working so
hard to stay so cool and now he doesn't
have the money and that that weird the
necropsy Simone says all times the
biggest mistake is thinking you're cool
well Johnny Depp has been holding that
yeah look at the way the guy dresses
what do you do when someone tells you
you're cool every 10 seconds for 30
straight years you wear any of the chips
that hang deep out of your pot you have
so many that guy has more worth and
leather bracelets than I do in home
take so much work to get dressed him oh
I'm at the Glendale Galleria and they're
those billboards for his cologne suave
aaj and what are we doing he's wearing
eyeliner here ya know right he's got
he's got stay humble and be humbled
you're not no go home and read a book
about Ward or grandpa aged man he looks
old look at the tattoos and he's getting
plastic surgery you're like come on man
this isn't the move he looks very very
he looks he looks drawn but what happens
is when I think he drinks a lot I think
there's a lot of from what I read in
your lost honor I don't know there's a
lot of smoking to smoking occasion
mm-hmm but you watch that guy's Inside
the Actors Studio he's cool [ __ ] man
yeah by the way talented good great I
recounted them there's a lot of vanity
going on man that's all that's that's
what we were saying earlier about like
to page you're like okay you there's it
tells me something when you can't let
something go like you're not cool enough
you still got a do like get like you'd
like care that much about your hair or
your face or like it's not enough it
hasn't been enough the adoration you get
that's why I love like Marlon Brando got
so big he was like what I did I did I
what do you want from me I've felt sexy
enough yeah what do I want my was a
super fact I just want to eat leave me
alone right himself forever he should
just there's a I don't like the waste of
potential or I think he goes back to
that like fame they had the attention if
you buy into it Ken because he keeps
having to do it that's a lot of work
just like I don't have the energy like
the amount of bracelets and it's high
those and put those on yourself I was
listening to things you can run around
like there's I love design and I love
the way clothes and sneakers look but at
some point I had to realize while I love
those sneakers they will look stupid on
me like I can't wear them where it's
like I look I'm like yeah they're
fluorescent they look like space boots
but I would look idiotic like yeah I
don't understand wait I don't have the
hair or the look for it on either one of
us have the hair for it now well if I
had that hair it would be very tempting
to be cool as [ __ ]
I wear all black basically all the times
I'm like stop looking at me I'm only now
I'm a product of my skillset and that's
it
well what all this stuff that he's done
worked for him he was that when he was
younger
was undeniably cool it's like did you
see that documentary about Tower Records
so all things must pass Colin Hanks made
it but Tower Records grew every single
year until it failed yeah like they grew
exponentially like everything then it
also was like nope they had no reason
not to keep expanding because I only
worked technology came along yeah it's
very the we are limited as far as our
perception of what we should and
shouldn't do
well that's also like we are also
limited that we don't know the with the
destructive force of the future and we
never stop with my babies that want
attention yeah ever
yeah that's damn that's pretty damn I
love when I see like when I'm in Beverly
Hills and you see a guy like an old guy
who's got a new wife and she took him
shopping and it's like new clothes new
clothes new clothes same shoes cuz that
guy's feet [ __ ] hurt like you're not
like he's like I got my doctor I'll yell
at me if I get different shoes yeah
that's orthopedic does Mephisto got
foreigner bucks that's how you know a
guys rich you're like those are
orthopedic shoes if you read Mephisto
you're looking at a guy with money
you're right
yeah they're four hundred five hundred
bucks but you see me as like babe I
can't I got a thing that you can't these
are these are is made for me I'm not
throwing these away you know that the
[ __ ] truth bro yeah ain't that the
truth
cuz his back's killing him he just had
surgery you're not gonna [ __ ] it up I
asked my wife if I could wear those one
time she was like they're not
bad-looking there's a pair that's not
that bad-looking on that I worked for
this commercial director I love those
brown ones that's how that's how boring
I'll never wear these guys yeah I love
those golden goose these are expensive
as [ __ ] that they are Dino sneakers made
by hand by a husband-and-wife team in
Italy yeah good shoes are worth the
money there they are
cuz it's your back in your feet Mel
thank those are converse they're not
covers David Letterman's set of things
halfway through the day change your
shoes it's like I putting on whole new
feet you really want to [ __ ] around put
on new socks yeah you're ready to change
the world
yeah well then you know I wouldn't
you're an actor you should you should
get the shoes right they'll change how
you do it it makes you what it changes
your walk I'm sitting too much I was on
a plane for 13 yes we're gonna talk
about your trip that much was there
anything cool exciting fly just that I
didn't do enough I had the best duck
I've ever had
microphones fine your mic I had the best
I had the best girl Mike I had the best
duck I've never seen him Mike roll its
eyes before that's what ya get my gives
a [ __ ] my trip was [ __ ] because I I got
to Beijing and I and I found out we had
to drive to a half hour so I said before
we go I have to eat and I want authentic
Chinese woman said are you sure you want
Chinese I want I want real Chinese she
goes because we can go to McDonald's I
go listen to me
I want Chinese food so we went to this
Chinese restaurant they had bullfrogs -
we had duck feet yes and mustard wasabi
they had they had turtle soup they had
small turtles or big turtles in soup
chicken viscera so you had chicken guts
I see if you can't remember China has a
lot of people to feed and they go we
went through family use all of me
you eat everybody use all you get
everything and then I had but I had pork
and like would you think it's pork it's
something heavily spiced Hunan [ __ ]
that's heavily supposedly you don't know
what you don't know that means she said
she goes you don't know and vegetables
and but I have to say that it's good
like you're you're gonna need some spicy
[ __ ] my skin didn't like it my skin
didn't like it my skin hated it but cuz
I get psoriasis oh so so everything
blurting I know I know it's hot but
having said that and then we drove to
junjin which is a sprawling city of 10
million at least I shoved into a space
as big as Glendale yeah and things are
things on a movie set in junjin are or
in China in general are not the smooth
running machine that is Hollywood a lot
of people don't know because they're not
experienced that film industry's about
10 years old so there's a lot of
glitches there is no air conditioning
and it's 95 degrees inside you're
assuming it was a very intensely
uncomfortable yeah and then when I went
to the old part of dungeon well there is
no real old part it was there some mark
structure built by the British back in
the day but that's all been turned into
shops that look that that are selling
the things you
Hollywood Boulevard and it was so hot
and I when they dumplings at a street
restaurant a place where you go yeah and
and even the woman I was with who was
Chinese it was from Beijing was like I
can't me junjin is not it is it is a
again this is from a westerner who only
saw very little of it but from what I
could tell when you walk around you're
just seeing those now you spelled ti a
and GI n you just see it's giant
buildings it's a vertical experience
it's concrete everywhere and it's it's
it's just it's it's not the prettiest
place what are you in that after taxes
for that job like would you bring on no
okay yes but it's my friend's movie good
time oh yeah Megan Fox Josh Duhamel is
the great people oh great love him but
but but but but uh Joshua I'm sitting in
China shooting in China is it is an
experience and and it's it's gonna be
it's going to be different and it's
gonna be it's gonna be you know it's
gonna have its challenges I have a lot
of respect for Chinese people but it's
it's not a movie we're in together I
want to go see China I want to see China
the way you should see China with some
of these Chinese who can take me from a
fighter jet attacking no no no that's a
no that's crazy
taking over a territory from behind a
rifle no no no does that what you mean
that's not what I mean but I feel like
that's what you mean no that's not what
I mean I don't want to be I don't want
to colonize my cockpit I don't wanna tap
into yourself tap into your lynnie no I
don't want to talking a lot about
history I want you to colonize China
what your people started out in this
world you know sorry you're good at
don't want to colonize China huh I want
to that's but thank you for from the
behind a right no I want to see China I
want to see China I want to I want to be
I yes I want to be carried on shoulder
yeah is the rickshaw Chinese or Japanese
I think it might be Chinese that
certainly Southeast Asian look China is
it it's very different it's not going
anywhere no I want to go see the parts
of China I want to see Shanghai the
parts of China yeah okay here's what I
should say about China you get a sense
with China and you're right when you get
this sense I'm sure that when you go to
China as a foreigner as an American is
shooting a movie there that there is
you're not gonna see anything of China
no nothing they're not letting you see
you are only going to see China if you
live there and you learn the language
and you are friends with people who live
there and you will see an under tapestry
there's an under tapestry there's a
subterranean yeah flow that is not privy
to your eyes sir yeah until you invest
in China yeah if you invest in China
it's like learning the language you want
to learn Chinese if you want to learn
how to read the newspaper in Chinese I
will see you sir after in ten years
yeah and that study better be dedicated
10 years for real but that means if
you're training living there and
practicing it every day yeah otherwise
[ __ ] off although I did meet a Russian
guy who is there all the extras were
Russian all of them and there was one
woman from Congress beautiful woman from
Congo who is every bit of 6 - and a man
from Zimbabwe who was getting his
medical degree there who is about a big
six too big but everybody else was
Russian playing Americans and you're
they spoke English
scully of podcast number he always loved
to say how tall and heavy a guy was he's
like big fella 6 to 235 pounds yeah and
then some arcane fact that would be me
loves from 185 no-neck close that
shoulders big arms a small feet and high
insertion calves men Eve's fast I'll do
that all day but the the the Russian guy
who is the extra said yes it's a lot of
opportunity here is good because there's
much opportunity and then he broke into
fluent Mandarin and I said you speak
Chinese because yes you nice and hard
you know I said I wanna take about one
year it's easy you know I go did you say
it's easy it goes yeah it's you know
it's different and then I the English
very
but you know in the but Russian I mean
Russian English very easy of course but
Chinese is difficult but it's not too
hard in a manner and I was like dude
[ __ ] are you speaking what this is so
easy between Russian English and
Mandarin just back and forth go to like
Scandinavia and everyone's like what
language do you speak I've got it right
now you are so lazy because they have to
because they we don't even learn Spanish
don't need to I want to learn Spanish me
did you know seems like a dumb I'm gonna
get back into my French French is a
beautiful language and the French I say
say say the French are very fine French
is long very important philosophy just
the sense of their their attention
Beauty the French have contributed much
to this action to this country to say
nice fashion yeah fashion man philosophy
again Chechens one of those lighthouses
that people who were different or like
wait I can go there yep and go work
there all day Lafayette the Frenchman
was the laid Washington DC out like the
spokes of a wheel where Ben Franklin
apparently figured out what macaroni and
cheese was wasn't for and Franklin spent
some time in France so if you like
macaroni and cheese and we know you do
because you're not an idiot
yeah thank you France the fall mush I
think they're America but the French and
the Belgians are arguing right now about
who invented french fries they want to
lay claim to it I think they say that
they say that cheese originated in
Turkey but who knows again these are old
old old places and when you go to them
you're like Charlie this is what they
were doing some stuff here for a long
time well that's why I rock it's like a
rock the Americans come in Bush it's
gonna is gonna restructure the Middle
East interesting it's where it's where
wasn't it Babylon they've got a
historical footprint that's 5,000 years
old yeah you Americans are gonna come in
and tell the Iraqis how to do it or
you're using our numerals still but tell
us again how we get to use them here
shut the [ __ ] up yeah [ __ ] up yeah I
mean did they come on
hey there they've been around arrogance
serves you very little in this life
hubris everyone next current event
please but you maybe think a couple
things uh well how did China smell first
of all it is no no well that's because
Bangkok smelled like like there was a
lot of fish and warming system in the
room because I've been Italy I live hi
there the awestruck by the aqueduct [ __ ]
they were in yeah the Chinese are
technologically sound yeah they've moved
you don't get internet you're not
getting Google new you're not getting
Twitter you're not getting it again they
they have that [ __ ] down on lockdown
you'll get by the way when you go into
China you you are you will give them
your thumb prints you will give them
your right hand and left hand
fingerprints you will give them your
face you don't you they record
everything and oh by the way I was given
a Chinese phone to use I was given a
cell phone by that made and controlled
by China yeah and I will use WeChat and
their internet their system of
communication because that can be
monitored yeah and it is monitored by
the government's best yours they were
like they read guy everything you said
yeah well it'll porn and also just the
fact you're not getting more horn you're
not you can get but but you break
through the internet because they can't
control it so there are different
servers that they'll tell you to log on
to to get your Google and to get your
stuff and then it gets shut down and you
have to start all over again
so when you are working in production
and you have to look things up and do
stuff you need your Google but but you
have to go through it through service
you have to circumvent their Security's
forces their firewalls and they got a
lot of firewalls so they control
information they control what you see
they control the historical narrative
that is China they so the young people a
lot of young people are not going to
hear about Kahneman Square young lot of
young people aren't going to hear about
these things yeah young people are told
the narrative is controlled to the best
of their ability and you think that they
couldn't but the Chinese government has
been able to do it to a large extent but
it's a losing battle and where do you
fall on that philosophically I think
it's terrible team sports versus
individuals I don't
agree with it I don't agree with any
central authority I don't agree with any
but happen come on and avoid total chaos
the the the great experiment that the
United States has contended with from
its inception was a republic has to have
a strong central government but the
founding fathers argued vehemently about
the the how much authority should a
central government have should we have a
standing army I mean so so Americans
Americans on the left and the right but
Americans have always had a very healthy
distrust of the federal government this
conspiracy theory this stuff with Bush
talking about fake news this stuff about
we can't trust the FBI we can't trust
our institutions this is not new this
has been this is part of the American
character and probably to an extent an
important aspect I don't agree with the
crazy conspiracy theorists I don't like
like Alex Jones and stuff but it has its
roots in the American character the
American character is what is to
distrust central authority and authority
in general I don't think that's a bad
thing i I am and I think I'm a guy who
believes in in small government if that
makes me right-wing okay you can label
me any way we want but I I am always
distrustful of central authority and
there is a movement toward socialism in
this country I think it's very
destructive very dangerous because
because if you create a powerful central
authority in the in the name of giving
those who don't have power more power
what's gonna happen always always is the
people who are who are delineating that
power or gonna take power themselves so
if you're closer to the government you
will have more powers exactly what
happens in communist countries you
create an elite that elite just happens
to be aligned with the forces that be in
Beijing or in Washington DC and so so be
careful decentralize power the
individual should reign supreme that's
how I feel that's the American Way
and I think I'm and I think history
bears me out and I feel if you haven't
noticed very strongly Marxism and
socialism are to me they ultimately the
people that believe them are not evil
but I believe that they lead their the
hell is paved down that path I sometimes
think people that feel the way you do
sometimes tend to lean towards that side
because you're a smart talented person
and not everyone is born smart and
talented it's a bit like height
intelligence is a thing that it can be
developed but also you can be born with
just less of it you've warm with less of
IQ it's like any other Talent yeah and a
lot of us who are like let people do
what they want individuals like some
people genuinely don't know what they're
doing and don't know what to do well I
felt that way I mean thank you for the
comment but I have to say I had dinner
with Peter Thiel and he's the guy who
created he was like he's that first
investor on Facebook and he's three
billion dollars is he that he's the the
whole Cogan yes yes hey the lawyer your
deal is is if you look if you watch
Silicon Valley the guy in the first
season's who was that really powerful
guy down Gawker
yes yeah and Peter Thiel is so smart
like I was I was having dinner and I
first of all I spoke too much at the
dinner I should shut the [ __ ] up you
listen to that guy because he's so smart
it was Erik Weinstein whose amazing coin
the idea the the term intellectual dark
web who I love but Peter when you listen
to him speak you go oh that's why you
have three billion dollars oh you think
CI when I talk I I regurgitate yeah the
things I've read and I put them together
yeah I do I parrot quill two variables
brain it's a quilt above the people's
brains that's how that's Bryan Callen I
admit it freely yeah I remember [ __ ]
that's what almost all of us are not
Peter teal no Peter teal comes up with
his own constructs and his own ideas and
it's incredible I'm dying to get him on
the podcast I'm just such a fan
yeah and he's young easy you're younger
than me which hurts me when you're
around when I'm around actual smart
people you're like oh oh wait oh wait
yeah he's I should just zip it he's just
he's just a bad [ __ ] and by the
way I mean first investor in facebook
he's on the board of Facebook I mean
Craig WA he was what with the PayPal guy
along with you people that see things
coming that far away I mean that guy
would say Howard Schultz to go started
Starbucks yeah his he's met his wife's
dad was kind of a successful dude was
like come work for me I can't have my
daughter your this isn't gonna work
this coffee thing you're doing it's like
I look I love you you you're a great guy
you seem like a good dude yeah but this
is [ __ ] I can't have her living like
if he's like just wait just wait he saw
it he was like no no I see this there's
going to be millions of them and people
are gonna come and sit and hand me five
dollars for a thing they paid a dollar
for the day before yeah and when you see
it work you're like what I see I mean
there's it you see it in everything
skateboarding everything there's a great
there's this guy Pat Duffy was the first
guy to grind down a round handrail that
was kinked and the skater goes I can do
it cuz I saw Pat do it who the [ __ ] told
Pat to do it like who how did he see it
he just looked at it was like okay it's
that weirdness those those people where
you're like okay man I guess you're on
there are people that exist on other
planes yeah they just there's some of
the special people you're like okay
you're on another level thing like we're
all talented whatever but like you see
the world differently it's almost
smaller to you and where you can see the
whole board it's like a great chess
player yes you did a documentary Magnus
no son Netflix about this like young
Chet he's only youngest grandmasters and
nothing I love those footages of when
they get one of those guys like a young
Grandmaster and they haven't played like
20 people at once who were quote-unquote
they're not professional too good yeah
and they just this kids handing them
their ass he's playing 20 games at once
and kicking the [ __ ] out of all of them
like he's like he just woke up like he
sleep off he's like click click and
every time he walks by and does it the
player a grown man in his 40s is just
like oh [ __ ] like they see the moon
they're like oh [ __ ] because they didn't
see it did you read the book the art of
learning by Josh Waitzkin no he was a
chess prodigy and he said it's six years
old he just he'd they everything looked
familiar to him it's just so weird and
he breaks down why he can beat 50 people
at once it's because he's seen the
chessboard so many times you haven't so
he has already been he's played that
game 50 times yeah 55 thousand times so
he goes oh I see what you're doing and
there's just no hay here his kids a
sweetheart - it's great dr. Henry yeah
and he's from likes I think it's Candy's
German or something he's well he's Matt
what's his name Magnus magnify from
Iceland any maybe I think he's from the
land Crossland really thick hair great
hair language Carlson that looks like
either Swedish or or Iceland that chess
playing brain is really something really
something I love watching those guys
kick the [ __ ] out of 20 people at once
Norwegian okay no way Scandinavia is
very interesting interesting from a
sociological is perspective because they
seem to have made it work but it's also
way less sort of yeah yeah low number
really bad everybody I [ __ ] every
academic who's a socialist is on my
podcast everyone uses the Scandinavian
model it's so laid out and it's so
boring cuz you're like in a bad example
i well so not really that well with a
guy from scandinavia and he was like you
can't break out you have to wait in line
to do anything in your life yeah believe
me it's got its there wire driver and
scandinavia was this guy who was a
magician he was like guy was in charge
of picking me whitney up at the hotel in
take us to the venue wherever I forget
what country you're in and he was a
really good magician and so Whitney just
had him like open for us one of the
shows really and he was amazing and you
could tell you could feel this thing
inside of him like get me out of here I
want to be I want to break out of this
and but where he was it was like no you
turn 18 you go on the list to get an
apartment you go to college for free
everything's taken care of and that's a
beautiful thing but if you want to
assert your now I always say forget
right and left it just comes down to
what degree and what percentage of your
money and your your power and your
serenity do you want to give to a
governing body you have to to an extent
there you have to have government you
have to have little puppet but what what
percentage of your freedom of your money
of your decision-making just tell me
some people have no problem giving it 50
percent yeah for the greater good some
people have no problem giving you know 7
I don't feel comfortable with those
numbers my I tend to believe that if you
give people 90% or 85% serenity you're
probably gonna have a better world
because human beings are so complicated
and and you're gonna reward individual
initiative yet you're gonna have
inequalities the biggest problem is how
do we solve the problem that some people
produce a lot and most people don't
produce anything I don't know you don't
you can't it's not fair to live in a
world where you pay a brain surgeon as
much as someone who does basically
nothing someone goes to that degree to
teach themselves and learn a thing and
is it's arguably more important to the
whole need a whole the whole like when
you when you have to go get surgery and
you talk to a doctor you're like I'm
real glad you're here dude and they're
telling you [ __ ] you don't understand
but they seem confident where they come
up with a business idea or uh they give
them up with a product that you're
willing to pay for so when FedEx or UPS
came out and said hey you don't have to
rely on the US Post Office how old were
you when you first noticed the arrow in
the FedEx logo Jesus I it took me longer
than it should have but when you see it
for the first time you're like oh yeah
we solve the pall around you it has to
get there overnight
oh holy [ __ ] and somebody said let's do
this let's get let's figure it out and
we all paid for and they became a huge
company look at that arrow just sitting
right there oh you mean that arrow yeah
buddy never saw it Paul Rand not a dumb
designer designed the IBM logo Wow yeah
buddy
I never saw that exactly but now that
you know it's there holy [ __ ] as you
said the arrows I got it's a delivery
company and they put the arrow between
the Ian can you imagine the day he said
oh I see
do I see that um without knowing it yeah
probably
I don't know that Lee tells you what why
you like FedEx now I don't like blue and
orange you're not a Knicks fan but you
see that and you're like it'll get there
it's going a direction now it's going
left to right which is a Western thing
only it probably doesn't work in Japan
or China or Asian countries well in the
air right Arabic left right to left oh
yeah the first time you've got Japanese
coming why is it like this yeah like oh
you're reading to the wrong you ready
toward your heart right the Quran
written look at that arrow just right
there
plain sight hiding in plain sight that's
pretty well it's a bore and no one
thinks that Lowe was like sexy no
[ __ ] a man you know what else is a
great logo the Hartford Whalers W made
out of the tail good see that you know K
I love a good logo is like yeah cuz
you're an artist well it's usually a
visual pun oh that's hot [ __ ] you should
bring the team back just because the
logos so good dan that looks nice look
at that it's a whale's tail sexy so good
I love a good logo whalers yeah
Philadelphia Flyers a great logo yeah
beautiful why red it's just beautiful
red wings it's not it doesn't have a
clever twist but it's be like twists be
like a twist board with what's it oh the
big ten the old Big Ten logo were the
hole in the tent of zeros and eleven
that's a smart [ __ ] low because there
was 11 teams not 10 that's a good one
dude oh look at me 11 look at the 11
damn this graphic designers deserve
respect you figured that out how do I
hide an 11 in the your like I got a
making it do you know the Pigpen has 11
teams like what do you mean yeah are you
gonna change the name of the big 11 no
make a logo what do you mean how do i we
need to know there's 11 teams how and
then some porn nerd who looks probably
just like me hunched over a table for
days what we would we didn't have nerds
we wouldn't have iPhones so shut the
[ __ ] up you can be nice to your nerds if
you're on school your skateboards
wouldn't have graphics on them
exactly next was so smart the rickshaw
was Japan and then you guys were talking
about child stars did you see Macaulay
Culkin on Joe Rogan's podcast no no it
was pretty interesting
he kept he's like a normal just a goofy
I heard a rumor that's because when he
was about doing home alone too they
realized that someone at Fox was like we
got to hide some of this kids money in a
place no one can get to it because the
people in charge of him are suspect it
was like some family people like there
was like maybe a dad or a septa that
they don't flock with anymore there and
they put a chunk away and it kept him
well taken care of he's got money yeah
he said he said yes what he wants
set
I mean home alone was a cache what what
does he do though now he just started a
comedy website he's taking he has people
submit I don't even think it's super
public but he has people like you can
just write for him he wants to have like
a funny website full of funny things I
don't know what to what degree it's at
right now he's an interesting dude
though he's seated seems I had a show
business he seems to have survived being
a child star by just pulling out of it
completely I mean he did the Larry he
got out of he got out of Hollywood zzzz
Larry Clark did some cool photos of him
you know harming Korean he come out with
some weirdo artists yeah you got to pull
you so mad back in the day I think he
moved to New York and stayed there which
is a smart thing to do if you're a young
famous person with money yeah I see him
skateboarding around I was like yeah he
was kind of part of that like early 90s
New York art thing alleged gallery and
just that dirtbag street art kind of
Beautiful Losers thing mm-hmm
just around those people cuz New York
doesn't give a [ __ ] who you are like
eventually they're like what do you do
when you're in the architecture of New
York it's like Beijing it's you're
you're when you're sort of dwarfed by
these massive buildings and everything
you you can't feel that cygnets like
being in front of a giant tree go to
Naples yeah like I ain't actually it
exactly go to Naples and see those giant
marble buildings I've been there for a
thousand years
enjoy enjoy feeling significant the
Parthenon with that hole in the middle
where the rain comes through it lands on
the floor it doesn't go anywhere cuz
they tilted the floor just enough it
just goes on and disappear so yeah like
you [ __ ] brilliant bastards in the
dome doesn't the Brunelleschi's dome
you're like how where did you start
how'd you figure it out you were the
first it was the big as they measure the
circumference of the earth shadows that
[ __ ] when they're like they could only
explain it so simply oh he noticed this
curvature and they noticed this started
like back up yeah you know it's still
the most confusing thing to me is the
photograph some guy was like no I bet if
we dip this piece of paper and mercury
and then the Sun had said but we put it
like oh it's shut up are you a wizard
you're a wizard
your Europe you're basically oh is it
did you figure that it's again it's like
the ancients there's this chronological
snobbery this idea that everything we've
done now is better than and everything
old is [ __ ] none on homie go back to
your history man who next you've got
this is a body Brian John Joseph was
talking about he on drogas podcast about
a fight some crazy fight you're in yeah
do you know about this you're in one
where they told you identify it
let me hear this I was invited I was
like hopefully we get along and have a
[ __ ] Toby I have massive respect you
know Brian's a crazy [ __ ] I tell
story you know that whole school down
there was a [ __ ] III wanted to tell the
story about Brian cuz he write account
yeah [ __ ] he's hilarious
so this guy's accent tells me he beats
people pretty hard Tony our team is one
of the senior students a master Choi
another guy will call him Chuck but he's
with the government now he's a [ __ ]
bad [ __ ] so they always used to
go around and and and wanna fight
bounces and all this [ __ ] that was what
they did they would [ __ ] fight the
biggest scariest looking [ __ ]
and just destroyed him so blue worked I
said his name sorry cro-mags and we took
him out security when else in case we
had problems or whatever so it was like
everything always went smooth so one
time I used to work it all the
underground hip-hop clubs in New York so
my friend was doing a party and it was
all [ __ ] deep brooklyn heads [ __ ]
like homeboys and [ __ ] like the real
deal this hip-hop Club and I take Brian
another dude from school and Tony and we
go over there and Brian is in the middle
of the [ __ ] dancefloor doing the
funky [ __ ] white boy nerd dance and
all these [ __ ] and the floor just
opens up and these [ __ ] black [ __ ]
hip-hop crazy [ __ ] homeboys are like
yo look at this [ __ ] white boy
like it's bugging and he don't give a
[ __ ] he's seriously like a [ __ ] piss
ative to roll with so then I might go
I gotta go but listen man I know what
y'all [ __ ] do don't start no
[ __ ]
please it's my friends club so I get
home go to sleep wake up the next day I
get a [ __ ] phone call
yo like he didn't know that they were
with me so I killed it was these three
[ __ ] karate experts in the club last
night and they beat up all my [ __ ]
bouncers dude it was [ __ ] crazy like
and one bouncer walked up and started
some [ __ ] with Tony was trying to talk
to a girl whatever and and then like you
know this guy is all on the juice rips
off his shirt like [ __ ] Tony throws a
kick [ __ ] dislocates the guy's
[ __ ] knee cap and then the first
mutiny the melee just ensued any it was
just constant these [ __ ] huge
bouncers coming at him and Brian's like
Popeye [ __ ] Brian could fight Brian
is uh you know nothing he's a comedian
but he could throw down and then Brian
just told me this because I didn't hear
the other part he goes yeah then all of
a sudden I'm [ __ ] whacking these
dudes and us
we're fighting these guys and then this
[ __ ] gigantic [ __ ] like I was
just like a little [ __ ] baby in his
arms lifts me up and carries me out the
[ __ ] door and throws me across this
car and I look and I turn around and I'm
ready to go and then Brian says and I
look and it's this [ __ ] crazy white
dude with a [ __ ] scar from one end of
his face down his throat and he points
that mine it goes don't even think about
it and like Brian was like y'all well my
friend called me up the next days like
these [ __ ] and I call him up
and I'm my Bryant the [ __ ] did you do
man I told you guys to [ __ ] keep
chilies like y'all these bouncers were
[ __ ] and you know it was he's he's
he's a character like I said I was at
his first comedy show ever he lived a
wild of life in his young days yeah I
met him after all that stuff I met him
when he was more calm I met him in the
90s yeah
yeah yeah they were in a statue anyway I
wish I wish I wish I was crazier then
and that makes me sound like a tough guy
which I never was but I did get in I I
did that that story is funny because
what really was going I was we're at the
club we were kind of drinking and I
never look for fights I never you know
but but when you're young and you're
flirting with your own mortality and
you're over an issue and this is before
to Jitsu and I would you know I've got
wrestled and I was obsessed with
Taekwondo I don't want to only hit
tennis balls against the wall you want
to play I say for me being the the [ __ ]
that I am but but at least I did go to
tournaments and I back then you did
fight you did try to knock each other
out Taekwondo like when you're like in
tournaments you you people get knocked
down you get you get knocked out and you
see you do kick people and you do and my
teacher was a boxer so I was hitting
mitts and stuff like I'm about to
greenbelt well yeah but so I I was
obsessed with it and I tried to be the
guy I'm not which is be a real fighter
right but in this particular case we
were there in these [ __ ] two dudes
I'm with my buddy and I'm just there to
try to pick up girls and this [ __ ]
guy rips his shirt off and I remember
going that's how the best body I've ever
seen he wasn't even the bouncer he was
just this big huge muscular guy and then
my buddy is standing in front of him and
this fight kind of breaks out over here
this kind of shoving that and he looks
at my buddy and he pushes my buddy
and so my buddy just goes baa pop-up and
like just catches him and didn't the guy
next to him
he pulled his shirt off and he had the
best again I went is such a good [ __ ]
hahaha
and he came at me you know and then I
you know I he wasn't a fighter you know
and I was I was doing that yeah but I
was so jealous of how big and muscular
and handsome he was that they did it
added to my might my insecurity and my
you know anyway and so I lived when I
hit him instead of fighting back he he
grabbed his face yeah you know it
what I thought it would be but the guy
the truth the forget all that stuff that
what really happened to me was as I'm
fighting this guy and this other guy the
the the it became up melee the [ __ ] I
did I got grabbed by a giant man who
started running me out and my buddy
who's a slick [ __ ] he goes get him out
of here
cuz he was gonna get thrown out but he
was pretending to help the guy on me out
of his mom's [ __ ] hat so I saw him
hitting him let's go no I'm helping him
and because they were gonna try to throw
him out so he ran out with him as he's
yelling and me pretending yeah you piece
of [ __ ] get him out yeah and the guy
took me I never forgot this but this is
not an exaggeration
from the door I remember he threw me and
I went oh I'm telling you this this is
not I I flew over the sidewalk and on to
the car landed for real like think about
that how big is a New York sidewalk he
threw me eight seven I don't know what
it is but he I went I remember going
through the air and I landed on the hood
of the car and I turned around I was I
was I was in a frenzy and I was yeah
yeah
you know you know and I and I did I saw
this giant and I've ever had this scar
and he was older he was probably yeah
you know 38mm and without but a but a
man yeah a bear a bear and and there was
nothing I might might Taekwondo is so
good here get on the stand her high
school wrestling decorate your hey
hundred and fifty fiver or whatever I
was I would have gotten [ __ ] and I
did he said don't think about it and
that in in that moment I went he did
sobered up in a when oh okay yeah no
problem
being on that anymore bigness is
fascinating yeah that kind of bigness
the way the body building stuff to me
when I was when you when you spend your
time enough time even now with boxing
and stuff if I see some giant muscle guy
yeah all muscular who really spends time
honest I'm not I'm gonna fight that guy
the guy I'm not gonna fight is the
athlete the guy I'm afraid of his the
young dude who who's got his ears or
he's got a neck I look at that
the neck is a real picture like I'm
gonna punch him in the head and it's not
gonna go anywhere and also by the way
happy afraid of every big calves yeah
dude
size are a big if guys got a big ass
you're gonna lose or or he's just a dude
there are plenty of guys who look like
nothing who will change your whole life
they're the ones by the way Bobby John
Joseph John Joseph that's the real deal
like he's real say I'm not I love that
he says I am crazy enough nodding it
wasn't it wasn't I wasn't I wasn't
fighting the money with a family of a
pudding boarding school I wasn't [ __ ]
that guy that's the guy in the lower
Eastside who used to meet me at Houston
Street cuz he had to walk me to his
house on Ludlow cuz I that's how the
lower Eastside he grew up with no family
he grew up they called him mighty wet he
in jail he went to Spofford Wow John
grew up harder than anybody I knew and
John in 1985 1986 1987 when all that
none of you were born in the Lower East
Side jaw when the Lower East Side when
the expression was a or adventurist you
could Avenue be or bolt see you're crazy
and D are dead John lived down there and
I met people through John from Hells
Angels - you name it who I mean
everybody respected John and everybody
knew what John was capable yeah John was
real and John had they be true street
cred like that that accent and all that
that's he grew up for real John had
tattoos on his body in 1987 you didn't
know anybody who had tattoos John
recovered and John would shred it built
like a brick [ __ ] and would wear
overalls only and walk down the street
in the Lower East Side and was a fun and
was a vegetarian was a Hari Krishna at
13 cuz that's all he had
so John John is a man with tremendous
character I love him there's that's one
of the best people I know people who
know the less people they have the
ability to quickly well he didn't have a
choice
so there's a difference in guys who
train and
like that who grew up really grew up on
the street yeah really squatted in
buildings really had no family yeah
really had uh here's what I wanted to
say this about him because it's
important
I saw John when John had no money John
would never take money like you you
could never lend John money I don't give
a [ __ ] how broke he was I remember one
time it was a well it was the winter
time and John had no money no no money
at all and I said what are you gonna do
any cuz I'll figure it out and there was
a guy there who was a homeless guy who
John saw it was too cold and John had
five dollars and John needed that five
dollars he really did and he gave it to
the guy and then John gave his coat
that's for real yeah John gave his coat
in the wintertime because John didn't
want us because he knew this homeless
guy and John didn't want to see him
called I've seen that [ __ ] give
when it really counted I've never done
that in my life so I've never even when
I really hurt I've given I give to money
and I give to it but I never give God I
don't know who I am when I don't know
who I am in those situations you've
never given a thing you didn't know
you're gonna be able to get back yeah
but I can't get it back no I've never
given anything that cost me yeah I've
never been in that position I don't know
who I am he knows who you people that I
find a fat people that have been to
prison and grew up really really hard
they actually are some of the most
empathetic people you'll ever meet in
your entire life don't listen to the
whole story like well he's in jail well
why yeah well what happened they want to
know it all because they know a lot of
people that have put in situation's out
of their control and got caught up yeah
you can get caught up yeah there are
certain cesare your friend what are you
gonna do when you have no other choices
all of us like to look down on people
that steal but if you have nothing and
no choices you're gonna [ __ ] do what
you ever you have to do yep I mean
that's why I'm taking this laptop that
monitors mine [ __ ] people look at you
extra extra monitor how dare you I know
it's a big monitor Here I am I've always
felt lucky I've always felt very
privileged and lucky I also I'm John's
always a reminder of how lucky and good
I had it yeah you need people in your
life like that who you're like like you
did so well you're like well I
pretty like exceptionally NZ my ears
still got my dad and mom mommy and daddy
I can still call them your parents are
still alive yeah [ __ ] your parents are
not my father is not your father
oh yeah that's a very sad story to me I
think about it all the time it was a
weird one yeah you were close to your
dad yeah dad Kevin's dad froze to death
right he got lost hiking and froze to
death in Big Bear right near Big Bear
place called Green Valley Lake Wow yeah
terrible you know it's funny or not
funny but when I when he bought about
that when he bought that cabin I mean
his whole life he was like Gavin you
have to promise me something if I'm in a
hospital dying you can't let me down a
hospital take me the woods and let me
die in the woods when he bought the
cabin he was like oh it's great up there
I hiked all time ago you're gonna fall
in the woods and I'm gonna have to go
looking for you to kind of laugh he's
like what I mean yeah that's how I'd
like the girls like 6060 too young too
young healthy healthy is [ __ ] he wanted
to go on he knew was gonna snow and rain
and he wanted to go on one last hike
before the weather came X he knew he
wouldn't be able to hike for like 3 4 5
days and that's all he loved doing was
hiking in the woods and he in the storm
X I drove up in it that night it was
raining sideways and he just couldn't
see anything so he couldn't figure out
where he was to find his way back and it
had just there'd been a fire up there so
there wasn't anything to build a real
shelter under he wedged himself kind of
under a rock but he also that pointed
high but he took his shoes off yet
hypothermia so it was like it was a wrap
but they didn't find him for months
really what God yeah cuz it snowed
snowed on him it was winter and I didn't
would date to say they found him is
inaccurate they found like you know did
remnants did you know that that's what
happened to him I mean I knew he had
talked to me enough over my life about I
mean they searched for him for 10 days
but after a day I was like he's dead
like I knew I didn't want to say it
because it was like the people these
searchers which these people were heroic
they do it for free
they have all they pay for all their own
gear and they go up there and they just
rip through the woods all day long
trying to find people I knew they
weren't gonna find him cuz he knew
enough about if he had been able to get
himself out he would have yeah and so
after day two I was like in my head I
was like look this is a fool's errand
was he married yeah my stepmom you know
man what a [ __ ] bomber you got are
less siblings I have an adopted brother
and two stepsisters
I'm biologically and ain't it hard every
one second hard he was a he was a super
good dude he was like I love he not take
that hard but again he was like
elementary school teacher his whole life
when he retired the kids wrote a song
about him like he was a beloved dude wow
he was the most straight-laced man I've
ever met like a real nerd not if not a
like designer nerd yeah he was a real
like short sleeve shirt and tie like
everything was brown never spent any
money I dad wanted to buy a Lexus his
whole life and every time he would go to
get a new car he would test drive a
Lexus and then buy a Toyota Avalon
because he could he knew they were the
exact same car yeah and he could not get
himself to spend an extra 15 grand on a
logo he's smart and all he ever spent
money I was golf equipment a real nerd
when I was 25 I go I feel like I don't
like funny ghosts yeah I don't like it
either that's how we are never drank
never did drugs really yeah even in
Vietnam didn't like tried pot once in
Vietnam she's amazing yeah he was a good
dude I think about it a lot because I
don't it was so shocking when I heard
that your dad died that way mm-hmm and I
don't know I think about it a lot
because it's such a it's such a weird
it's such a it's just an uncommon way to
go yeah it's a scary way to you know
yeah but it was it was odd I mean it you
know it took me a really long I don't
I'm not to say I'm over now but it took
it kind of sidelined my like emotional
and intellectual growth for like a
decade
did it really yeah we're and now I
realize it cuz it's been about 10 years
where I was like I was kind of in
tenured I was like a ghost for a while
yeah because I I spoke to you shortly
after and I think and I noticed I I was
I was taken with how even killed you are
but that's how you are me I'm gonna let
me know about how terrible it was but
yeah I remember I thought about it a lot
I mean yeah I thought about it a lot
that's really really really hard yeah
yeah I you know I don't know I don't
know that you know how to deal with
stuff like that I try I mean I went into
after O'Neill Brennan after like a few
years he was like every because you're
turning into a [ __ ] I was like what do
you mean I literally thought I was
perfectly fine he's like dude you're
turning into a [ __ ] he's like you're the
negative
I mean honestly that did probably you
could make the case he saved my life he
was like you need a therapist a minute
and my friends had been like you should
go to therapy but no one ever did
anything Neal found one in an hour
here's this person good friend he was
like where he knew I needed one like on
that side of town I was in the old
Brennan and he was like here's an years
a number and I was in therapy a week
later and that's what in that is what
slowly started to help yeah because I
was a kind of I didn't know it but I was
a kind of angry at existence in the
world and just the chaos of life and I
couldn't quantify I was snapped I mean
that's why I got to force I was just
like I was me I was made and like just
mean and cuz it was like it wasn't like
I was mean to the person necessarily
just so much as I was like I would say
things like you should get away from me
you'll have a better life it was that
kind of like I can't fix this not
amazing how trauma its fact it's it's
really fascinating I mean I'm incredibly
lucky person but there's been a lot of
death but I'm at the same time so lucky
otherwise but it's just I've you know I
don't know it doesn't mean it doesn't
suck no it's it is the catch-22 of
existence is everyone you know will die
I know and after a certain age
at my age now I'm 41 now's the time
where your friends start getting
surprised diseases dude tell me about it
I know III I've been really thinking
about like this has been the year where
everything could happen to me like me
and I'm like but I've been I've been
reading a lot and and and really really
getting into listening to bring up Alan
Wallace I've been listening to a lot of
Buddhism and a lot of I'm on I'm on some
old-school like be here now [ __ ] like
ramadasa Slyke nothing is real yeah we
are literally impermanence of life his
doc he did a short documentary about how
he's kind of like really getting really
old and he's gonna die soon
did we pause okay and he's like he knows
he's gonna die
he spent his whole life thinking about
it he goes he goes death is is taking
her foot out of a tight fitting shoe and
I was like you he goes it's just a
change he had a stroke so he needs all
this help like people take him to the
ocean to listen to how he speaks he said
something this guy's our Rinpoche too
and he's been he's like friends with the
Dalai Lama but he's a Buddhist scholar
and also a monk when you hear him talk
listen to his voice I'm sorry I want to
hear what you're saying tell me more
about so he and he so he has a strokes
he needs a let's help people like take
him the ocean to float him around he
goes being dependent has taught me so
much because you meet the people that
are dependable we were so ashamed of
like needing help like I'd have a bunch
of surgery this year and like you know I
hate asking for help of any kind but I
had to I had to help and I mean the
first day I'm home first of all my
friend Leslie Grossman brilliant comedic
actor and Whitney Cummings are fighting
over who gets to drive me I show up home
I'm there for an hour
Steve Howie's making soup in the kitchen
Whitney's there braids they both are
fighting over who gets to go buy
vegetables and [ __ ] and I'm like I'm a
[ __ ] lucky bastard over here yeah I
don't even know how to be like this is
when you need it if you you the people
that love you will show up and you're
like Jesus I think that's best Steve how
are you making you soup oh and with that
body I have a picture of it he'll if I
put it on the Internet women would would
sprint towards him this guy's making a
vegetable soup cuz I don't need meat
yeah he bought all these unnecessary
groceries and [ __ ] just skis he what he
went he was so excited to finally help
me right same Whitney
it was just like hi this is you know but
you meet the dependable when you're when
you become dependent fascinating that's
really cool
but yes shame is it's all do become the
Stalin Baltar listener psychology in the
same mood and so with that same mood he
proposed that psychologists like Darwin
like Galileo never mind yeah you got
it's not bad but no I'm trying to be on
this [ __ ] now to where it's like I
want to pull myself out of the thing
that the world is in right now well the
timing of it human beings it's not just
the world is the human the human
condition is to want all the time yeah
you know you define yourself on your
desires but you go from want to want to
want yeah and the Buddhists have this
idea of getting stepping outside of that
and it's why people ask me all the time
dude what do you sell your art and why
and I say no and they go why not and I
goes because it doesn't matter it
doesn't the making it is the thing to me
I'm it doesn't the the paintings like a
receipt do you frame the receipt from
Emil you liked not really you keep the
[ __ ] the receipt from a concert you
went to make it like kinda but it
doesn't matter it's it's this is the the
timing we think exists now especially in
the age of social media
showbiz timing isn't real we go staffing
season that's not a real thing yeah
there I there's a great book called the
history of time and it talks about when
they split from mechanical time to farm
time Earth's Sun time when they because
it's not the same if you go by the Sun
it's like 15 minutes off yeah well which
one's real which one you gonna depend
which one can you argue is real one was
ones nerd time and the other ones like
earth time so I'm gonna be like [ __ ] you
earth time dork over here came up with
another thing he's got this system right
and from then on we just subscribe to
this I all these various ideas it's like
when you tell my brother I walked about
my dad on Marin and my brother after the
fact was like what you said isn't
entirely true like cuz I was making fun
of on the way home he want to get beef
jerky I thought it was funny and like he
asked the rescuers have you go in the
helicopter yeah which is in retrospect
hilarious yeah also god bless he's
trying to enjoy himself during the worst
ten days of any of our lives and help
and he's like that's not what happened
and then he tells you me and I'm like
maybe your memories right and mines
wrong I don't [ __ ] know yeah have
it's why I don't talk about
relationships of my past relationships
in a way that's like well this is what
happened well we know Robert Evans quote
there's the there's three sides to every
story your side my side and the truth
and nobody is lying
literally no one's lying yeah perception
is so
perception is everything everything so
the notion that's as I get older I just
get quieter there's the idea of history
from my perspective which is from the
winters perspective a western man's
perspective versus history from someone
from China
someone from Vietnam someone from Russia
World War two from the Russian
perspective and cedar we're like honey
yeah what's it what's history yeah
what's history like don't do don't do
drag that's not how they talk honey yeah
yeah but I like them that's permanent
into the Russian mindset post-world War
two
you see what I know a Russian Russian
needs drag well there's a really good
direct quote yeah that's a Russian
character that's this whole thing it's
brilliant he's really catchy yeah I got
Tina Trixie they have a youtube show
that is insanely popular really yeah
they're hilarious hi Jen what Trixie all
right mark that down all right will do
Kevin Christina spy I measure you you're
goddamn good I never get to talk to you
I mean Lee described you as the funniest
person I've met you hear that more funny
words per sentence than most people
thank you sir you've kept yourself in
shape yes sir
you're still a fighting weight whether
you want a fight or not I'm ready
that's a boys a couple couple weeks out
bro but we I mean where you live so far
away be hard to play tennis I know Jay
Larson plays tennis to you guys I mean
where do you live where do we live in
Los Feliz yeah never happened that's the
problem with Kirk Fox do you know what
though I'll videotape it I'll send it to
you know we'll make some tapes but well
eventually we could find a Beverly Hills
Tennis Club sort of in the middle La
Cienega and like Pico yeah they got a
nice court go back or do you want to
grab some lunch I gotta go back I gotta
walk the dog yeah it's gonna take guy by
the way to get here more Street if not
for Google Maps can I know it's amazing
what we did where is Brendan this
weekend he is in no Dallas Dallas Dallas
Texas no see Brendan in Dallas Dallas
improv everybody talk about it huh I'm
not doing any standard right now but I
got a hair line August 30th I am having
a show at The Comedy Store get your
tickets I'm gonna have a crazy lineup
you can imagine
those lineups you have a pretty yeah
yeah pretty insane if you're around you
want to do one of my shows I would love
to all right we'll talk I drove this
year to copy on a podcast thank you
ladies and gentlemen
I want to thank Kevin Christie I want to
thank you back in my phone case jinkx
monsoon
jinx months and I want to thank her as
well for making the world wait more
interesting place way better yeah this
is the fighter and a kid we're out